Tim Ferriss: David, so lovely to see you.
David Maisel: It's good to see you, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: I had, thanks to your inspiration,
a fine matcha before sitting down and have
this conversation.
Thank you for that.
David Maisel: I'm honored to inspire you on
something like that.
You inspire so many.
Tim Ferriss: I'm putting together the coffee,
matcha alternating schedule, which seems to
be working very well for me so far.
Thank you for that.
I'm excited to have you on this show for many
reasons.
One of which is this is in a way a debut,
an audio long form debut.
I'm very thrilled to be able to explore a
lot of these things that will be scratching
my own itch in terms of asking questions that
follow my curiosity.
Let's begin, not exactly at the beginning,
not at conception, but a beginning of sorts,
and that is with Michael Ovitz.
How did you first connect with Michael Ovitz?
Who is Michael?
David Maisel: I mean, in the mid-1990s, Michael
Ovitz was the most powerful person in Hollywood/entertainment
by far.
He had created Creative Artists Agency, which
was already, at that time, the biggest talent
agency in Hollywood.
He had created this leverage by controlling
so many stars and by being this very mysterious
figure that he just became almost like The
Wizard of Oz, some mythical creature.
I remember I was debating a career switch.
I was working in consulting for entertainment
companies with Boston Consulting Group at
the time, and decided that my love of Hollywood
and movies, I had to move out to Hollywood
and really try it and not have regrets.
He was on the cover of Businessweek and I
just cold called him.
I sent him a letter, old-fashioned paper resume,
went to Kinko's to print it out, and I was
granted a five-minute interview and flown
out to L.A. That was the first meeting.
I remember he put me up at the Beverly Hills
Hilton and he made me stay two days waiting
for the meeting.
It just kept getting delayed.
Tim Ferriss: To dig into a few aspects of
that, we're talking about The Wizard of Oz
at the time.
David Maisel: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Wizard of Oz in Entertainment,
a power broker of high order.
He must have been having everyone and their
grandma and cousin trying to get a hold of
him.
What did you say in your cover letter, or
what was it in your resume?
What combination of factors do you think led
to you being granted an audience with The
Wizard of Oz?
David Maisel: It's a good question because
I think I pieced it together after a while.
I was fortunate to have a stellar resume,
but so do a lot of people that I'm sure were
approaching Michael at the time.
It was in retrospect, I think I can say this
now, Michael had been hired by Matsushita,
the Japanese company, to secretly analyze
and potentially sell their holding of Universal
Studios, which they had bought years earlier.
I was in the right place at the right time.
As a great agent would do, he sold that assignment,
but he didn't necessarily have people that
could do the work for him.
All of a sudden, he got this Harvard MBA resume
of some guy saying he'd be willing to work
and take whatever.
In many ways, I think it was just a really
fortunate timing that it came across his desk
then.
Tim Ferriss: You had the relevant experience
in mergers and acquisitions or that type of
deal analysis or no?
David Maisel: No.
I sort of joke, I mean, I was very into creative
things and I turned that part of my brain
off after graduating from Duke because I needed
to make some money and I figured my rational
brain was more predictable.
I went to HBS and I had the Harvard Business
School moniker.
I had a couple years at Boston Consulting
Group.
I think once I learned Michael, and once I
started working with him, that was the first
job, which was to secretly help him on that
assignment, which was amazing as your first
job in Hollywood to have this huge secret
that you couldn't share with anybody in town.
I had this office way in the back so none
of the other agents would know what I was
doing.
I was getting these secret emails between
Universal and the Japanese at the time that
Lew Wasserman, another mythical figure, was
not even privy to.
It was a blast.
I think he enjoyed having his token Harvard
MBA by his side that he could offer up to
his clients.
He did.
I was there for whatever that moniker might
deem to be useful for, whether it's Tom Cruise
or Warren Beatty or a company like Matsushita.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Now, if we take a step back, and since you
came to know Michael very well, you look at
what made Michael effective as a power broker,
what are some of the ingredients that made
him so effective?
Your description, as we led into this, made
me think of perhaps other comparables.
I'm sure very different people, very different
businesses would say like Larry Gagosian in
the art world or others who in these fairly
opaque, somewhat opaque industries just develop
relationships that give them an incredible
degree of leverage.
What are some of the sort of requisite components,
ingredients that made him so good at what
he did, because certainly he wasn't the only
person trying to be powerful or influential
in Hollywood?
David Maisel: Right.
No, it's interesting, Tim, because I ended
up being — I was employee number 400 out
of 400.
I quickly, because of this secret project
and the fact that it became pretty obvious,
he was also considering leaving CAA to run
Universal to whoever bought it, which was
cataclysmic at the time.
I had this secret and we flew to Japan and
all that kind of stuff together.
I became to his right-hand side and stayed
there pretty much through 1999, 2000, four
or five years.
I saw what he's notorious for, which is a
tenacity, and a focus, and a work ethic that
would not let anything but his success happen,
which was combined with a level of street
smarts on how this town works and a ability
to amass leverage and perceive leverage that
caused his wishes to get executed one way
or the other.
Then, also combined with amazing use of PR
to create this mythical image of himself.
Personally, I was able to watch that because
Michael is a controversial figure, that's
very clear from the history, but I was able
to look and see where we were similar and
where I might want to take a different path
in my own career, but if it wasn't for Michael
hiring me and giving me that break, I don't
think I'm in a position to do Marvel Studios
ever.
He helped.
I was naive as hell when I moved to L.A. I
was smart from a book sense, academic.
I had no idea about personal street smarts,
let alone Hollywood street smarts.
I was somewhat creative, I felt, but I didn't
know how this town really works.
Not only did I get to see Michael, Tim, I
had access to all the information at CAA,
all the deeds.
I just soaked it up.
Tim Ferriss: That's a big deal.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to pick a little bit
more at the origin story, not in a critical
way, but in a curious way.
David Maisel: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: If you have to speculate, feel
free to throw in the caveat that you're speculating.
Cover of Businessweek, putting himself in
these PR positions that would create a dynamic
that might help him do whatever it is that
Michael wanted to do, which I believe he also
imparted to Marc Andreessen and Ben Horowitz
when they were founding Andreessen Horowitz,
a16z, and they did a masterful job in turn
of utilizing targeted PR.
The reason I bring that up is he's on the
cover of Businessweek.
I have to imagine you are not the only business
school graduate to reach out to him.
Even if you have to reach, what was it that
— you're probably not the only consultant
either —
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — who reached out to him.
Why do you think you got the extensive five-minute
interview?
David Maisel: Well, there's two questions.
There's one, why the interview and the second,
which I think you're relating to too, which
is why'd I get hired, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yup.
Totally.
David Maisel: The interview one, it's a good
question.
Nobody's ever asked me that before.
It wasn't like I went through three people
to get to Michael.
I think I spoke to a couple other people that
same day, but Michael was on my schedule.
I had my time with him.
In that five, it was no more than 10-minute
period, I do remember connecting.
I don't know how, but I think he saw my tenacity
that I was willing and committed to do what
needed to get done.
I can't —
Tim Ferriss: He saw that through stories of
projects, assignments that you'd worked on
in the past —
David Maisel: Yeah, I can't recall —
Tim Ferriss: — or it's just a feeling?
David Maisel: — what he talked to me about,
but I'd gone to Duke.
I was number two in my class.
I was on the board of trustees when I graduated
as a student, a full board member.
I was —
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
David Maisel: — accepted right into HBS.
Yeah, I had his great — I produced the Broadway
at Duke series.
Not that that matters, but it was relevant
to entertainment.
He saw — you're right.
I mean, a lot of people have great resumes.
I think it was the energy together, but something
I've never told anybody is he didn't hire
me right away.
That interview happened.
I didn't hear anything back for a while, and
I started interviewing with other people.
I remember I had a job offer from David Stern
at the NBA, which was, wow.
I mean, we were just talking about the Celtics,
but this was, I had an interview with the
commissioner of the NBA and he hired me to
be vice president of Entertainment and I remember
he offered me 50,000 a year, and I was like,
"Mr. Stern, how can I live in Manhattan at
50,000 a year?"
He was like, "Don't live in Manhattan."
That was his answer.
I actually interviewed with Marvel and got
a job offer from Marvel at the same time as
head of business development when it was owned
by Ron Perelman.
I remember their Manhattan offices.
Then I got an offer from McKinsey, which was
like triple the money, which I needed, to
be a median entertainment specialist for them
worldwide, like a new position.
I literally accepted that offer from McKinsey,
moved to New York City, and started on a Monday.
I wrote a letter, an email, I forget what
it was at the time, but it must have been
a letter or an email to Michael and a guy
named Sandy Climan, saying, "Guys, just so
you know, I accepted another job at McKinsey."
On Wednesday I got a phone call from Sandy
Climan who was working for Michael, saying,
"Is it too late for you to join us?"
I gave notice on Thursday.
I was at McKinsey for one week, maybe it was,
I don't know.
Sandy gave me a note from Michael on top of
the letter I sent saying, "Is it too late
to get David?"
I think it was timing.
It really was the timing that pieced things
together, but I can't explain it.
Tim Ferriss: A little scarcity doesn't hurt
either.
David Maisel: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Having a bunch of excellent offers
doesn't — competing offers doesn't hurt.
David Maisel: Yeah.
With him though, you're right, your sense
that he was at the center of attention and
had his selection of things.
I do think in my career, when I look back
on it, I was very fortunate with some timing
issues, both with Michael and eventually with
Marvel.
I had to create both jobs, and I'm proud of
that, but I also approached them both at the
right time.
Tim Ferriss: I think anyone who has ever been
on this podcast who has achieved outsized
success, if they're being really honest, has
to admit there is a huge factor of timing.
They just have to, which doesn't demean or
minimize the hard work required to translate
that into amazing outcomes, but nonetheless,
it's an ingredient.
Let me ask you just a few more questions about
that period.
For people listening who are like, "We want
to talk about the creative stuff," we're going
to get to the creative stuff, but understand,
from my perspective, this is all creative
stuff.
David Maisel: Yeah, it is.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give you a sense of what
I mean, for those people who don't have context,
McKinsey, BCG, Boston Consulting Group, these
are, for many graduates of good schools, coveted
jobs, highly competitive jobs.
They're also firms within which if you play
your cards right and you keep your head down,
you can make a lot of money and it takes time
but that is one potential option.
It would seem to be more predictable, perhaps
more perceived as more secure, stable than
some of these options you were looking at.
David Maisel: Yup.
Tim Ferriss: What led you — and a lot of
people go into consulting with or investment
banking for that matter, and they say, "I'm
going to do this just for a few years, get
exposure to a broad array of industries, and
then I'm going to forge out on my own and
do something entrepreneurial."
That doesn't always happen, as you know.
David Maisel: Yup.
Tim Ferriss: What contributed to you at that
time deciding to branch, ultimately recognizing,
you did accept the job at McKinsey, but then
ended up with Michael, but nonetheless, to
explore options outside of consulting?
David Maisel: No, it was very personal.
I wish I could say I had realized this on
my own, but my sister, older sister passed
away and at young age, and I saw impermanence,
and I saw the fragility of life for the first
time.
It did affect me.
I knew I wasn't completely happy not being
creative, not at least trying to be out in
the middle of the action and in the arena
and quit BCG soon after that.
When I wrote Michael that letter, I was back
home living with my mom, which wasn't — now,
that's popular to do.
Back then, it really wasn't.
I ended up taking the McKinsey thing because
I had run out of money that I had saved from
BCG.
I was forced to take something.
I think I tried to learn poker at the time.
I was losing some money at the games that
were going on.
It was a gift for my sister, frankly, to make
me realize that we should try to live to minimize
regrets, if possible.
Tim Ferriss: I'm so sorry to hear that.
I imagine that must have been really challenging
for your whole family and for you.
David Maisel: Yeah.
It was really a beautiful gift though, because
I think I might not have been, have the backbone
to, like you say, a lot of people talk about
branching out, but you can get really secure
at those places.
I was headstrong.
In fact, when Michael offered me the job,
he said, "What are you making at McKinsey?"
I told him and he said, "We'll match that,
but there's no guarantee, and I can fire you
tomorrow."
It was a gamble.
It was definitely a gamble.
Tim Ferriss: "How am I supposed to live in
Manhattan?"
"Don't live in Manhattan," and it's —
David Maisel: Yeah.
Especially from the commissioner who had just
signed this huge deal with the owners.
It's like, "Come on, you're not shy for money
at the NBA."
Tim Ferriss: It's kind of an amazing answer,
though.
You're like, "I can't really…"
Hard to refute, in a sense.
Let's come back to something that you've mentioned
in passing, but the creative interests that
you turned off in favor of developing or honing
in on your rational, analytical mind.
What were those interests?
David Maisel: It was, primarily when I grew
up, acting in theater and I was an actor in
high school and love live theater, and luckily
my career brought me to have the chance to
produce multiple shows, which I've really
enjoyed.
I also just love culture and entertainment.
Star Wars was a huge impact.
The idea of crafting mega cultural movies,
to me, as a creative producer, as a business
producer combined, was really exciting.
It was really show business in general.
I knew my acting skills were not that great.
They're pretty bad, but the idea of being
a creative producer on Broadway or film, that's
what seemed the most exciting to me.
Tim Ferriss: I want to quote someone and then
get —
David Maisel: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: — a little insight from you.
This is a quote from, I believe, I'm getting
the pronunciation right, Kevin Huvane —
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — as quoted in the New York
Times and the quote is, "David has..." this
is in sort of brackets, but, "...encyclopedic
knowledge of comic books and treats them like
real art with savant-like ability to take
out characters that appeal to him and make
them really relevant."
When did your relationship with comic books
begin?
David Maisel: Early.
I mean, it was probably a lot of us, something
I loved as a kid, probably when I started
reading, five or six, and Marvel specifically,
but overall comic books and Iron Man specifically,
but a lot of characters.
I'm excited to see the new Flash movie that's
coming out.
It was something, I remember my mom, I used
to joke with her recently before she passed
that she would tell me to stop reading my
comic books and focus on schoolwork.
It turned out to be my career.
It was pretty ironic.
Kevin, who gave that quote, I remember being
touched by that because when I joined CAA,
back to Michael, Kevin Huvane, and Bryan Lourd
and Richard Lovett, the three people who are
predominantly running CAA today and took over
the firm when Michael left and are arguably
some of the — if not the — most powerful
agents in town.
We sort of grew up together in the mid-'90s
working for Michael, and it was an unexpected
quote when I saw that, but it was nice to
hear his kudos coming from his position.
I guess we did do some deals.
Natalie Portman was his client, who was in
Thor and many others, as well from CAA.
Comics were always an interest.
Marvel specifically, Tim, was a fascination
with me.
Even before I got that job offer when I was
talking to Michael, when I was at business
school over beers, some of my friends and
I were like, "We need to leverage buyout Marvel
from this vitamin company that owned it."
It was completely tilting at a windmill and
nothing came from it.
Tim Ferriss: What a fun windmill to tilt at
though, while you're slamming back beers at
HBS.
That's great.
David Maisel: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Foreshadowing, I think that's
what they might call that.
Before we get to Marvel, what are other lessons
that you learned either from Michael or just
during that chapter of your Hollywood experience?
I would love —
David Maisel: I think —
Tim Ferriss: — to just know what kind of
principles or lessons you ended up absorbing,
best practices, anything that comes to mind.
David Maisel: Tim, I think there's a couple
that I'll point out, when was Michael really
taught me how to work with the creatives of
this town, because he put me in front of them.
I remember, it might have been the first or
second time I was ever with him at an industry
function.
He always, and I'll always give him credit
for this, whether he said it or not, but often
many times he said something like, "Hey, here's
a lesson here."
Tom Cruise was there.
He introduced me to Tom Cruise, and then he
said, "We'll be right back."
He took me to the bar and Michael ordered
drinks for Tom and whoever he was with and
brought the drinks back for Tom and whoever
was around him at the time, whether it's his
assistant or girlfriend at the time, I don't
know.
He mentioned to me, "Just remember, we're
always in the service business.
Remember who our customers are."
The fact he did that personally and didn't
ask me to go do it, or somebody else, was
like, "Whoa, this guy is at a different level."
I remember the second day I was there, he
brought me into a meeting with Bill Gates
at the time, who was, and they talked about
creating a competitor to AOL, and I saw how
he dealt with the tech and which, as you hinted,
became a big part of his life later on.
He always was on the cutting edge of technology.
He opened my eyes to keeping an eye out to
what's going on with tech and entertainment
and how those two industries are still trying
to figure out how to work together.
Michael was sort of ahead of the time on that.
Then, I guess, third was all of us have to
figure out our personal style and approach.
I saw how there's choices to get made on how
you sort of learn about Hollywood and progress
through Hollywood.
That, to me, was eye-opening because I also
realized I wasn't very good at that game of
using leverage or the politics of what needs
to get done in any entity, but this time specifically,
Hollywood.
It was an eye-opening lesson for me.
Tim Ferriss: I asked a professor of mine at
one point what it was like working in DC because
he ended up being a congressman and spending
a bunch of time in politics.
He said, "It's like Hollywood, but with less
attractive people."
I always thought that was hilarious and probably
accurate on some level.
You have said before, this is from The Financial
Times, that to be really successful in Hollywood,
and you already alluded to some of this, one
needs to be very good at business fundamentals,
managing the creative process and street smarts
to understand the town.
Could you give an example of each of those,
perhaps case studies, times when you absorbed
lessons related to any of those, the business
fundamentals, managing the creative process
and street smarts to understand the town?
David Maisel: The first one, business fundamentals,
it became pretty clear to me that that was
an area that Hollywood was not very focused
on.
To this day, you probably can make the same
case if you look at some of these enterprise
values of the studios, but the idea of shareholder
value, the idea of the what creates a Disney
to be worth more money, or Universal, how
do you value a business?
That — the idea of value was foreign to
people.
To his credit, I remember Bryan Lourd, who
is running CAA now and is one of the most
amazing people in this town, and I say that
in all respects, but I remember him pulling
me aside back in 1995 and asking me to tutor
him on financial statements and shareholder
value and all those types of things.
Now, he's running this huge agency, you know
what I mean?
He's also saw the same thing and was wise
enough to realize it was something that he
could use to his advantage once he learned
it.
That actually becomes really important, because
later on, I realized the market here was inefficient
and that the fact I was able to do what we'll
talk about later with Marvel should never
have been able to happen if it was efficient,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Maisel: Then, number two, with the creative
process, God, there's so many things there,
but everything like that Tom Cruise story,
which is understanding them.
Michael also talked about always the people
around the star that it was so important to
have a great relationship with them.
Tim Ferriss: That's smart.
David Maisel: He exposed me to what a star
like that is used to in Hollywood.
Understanding that they have other people
around them that will be maybe whispering
in their ears, negative things.
You have to play defense and offense.
I was so fortunate, Michael put me in front
of so many people.
I remember him sending me to Warren Beatty's
house, just this icon and still is, to talk
about the stock market.
I only say this because it just shows you
how forward-thinking Michael was.
He gave me a chance to interact with this
megastar on a personal basis.
I got to training of —
Tim Ferriss: Now, did Warren just reach out
to Michael and say, "I want to learn about
the stock market.
Find somebody who'll help me?"
David Maisel: I think it was the opposite.
I think what I learned when I got there, because
I remember I sat with him for five minutes,
awestruck, and then he basically looked at
me and said, "Hey, kid, there's no way I'm
ever going to learn this.
I've had too much fun in my life.
I'm not going to start focusing on the stock
market."
Now, he might have used a different word than
fun with an F. It definitely was Michael tutoring
his clients.
I think Magic Johnson has been — publicly
talks about how Michael would get him a Businessweek
subscription and things like that —
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
David Maisel: — while he was a basketball
player.
Tim Ferriss: Magic has run with that.
He's been so —
David Maisel: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: — so good at executing.
Wow.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
David Maisel: The third, street smarts, wow,
I mean, that one, I just realized how small
this town is, Tim.
It really is.
It's a small group of people and still is.
Understanding what people want and how you
can make a deal by figuring out the magic
of delivering what they want by getting what
you want back and what people's, the street
smarts they'd say, wow, I've never talked
about this publicly, is to know that it's
what is their motivation.
Are they going for their annual bonus?
Are they going for the best seat in the restaurant?
Do they care about their stock options?
They care about their prestige?
Do they care about credit?
Many different people here are motivated by
other things.
Sometimes it was good, street smart wise to
figure that out.
It helped me the rest of my career.
Tim Ferriss: If someone is listening and they
say, "At some point I would like to set foot
into what we would broadly call entertainment,"
and they suspect they're going to end up in
Hollywood or L.A. or at least interacting
with groups from those places.
They're not going to have Michael Ovitz.
David Maisel: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: They may not have a direct mentor.
Are there any books or resources or docs or
they could just be scripted movies too, that
you would encourage people to watch to help
them with those buckets.
David Maisel: I'm thinking about that off
the top of my head.
There are biographies of Michael, of David
Geffen, of industry figures like that.
I think those are useful to understand the
history of the town.
I also am surprised, we used to have paper
trades, The Hollywood Reporter and Variety,
they're now all online, but how many times
I interview young people that want to come
into Hollywood and they're not really up-to-date
even on the current stuff that's happening,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Maisel: There's so much information
available that wasn't available to me at the
time.
Diving into history, through articles and
through biographies, and just keeping up every
day with what the latest news in Hollywood
is.
Even just those two things together, if you
don't have a mentor, you'll get the benefit
of a lot of learning, like in most areas of
life.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
And I'll reinforce a point that might not
be the sexy piece for a lot of folks, but
the business fundamentals, it's if you want
to, as you have done and we're going to segue
shortly, capitalize on inefficient markets
or asymmetric upside opportunities, having
a grasp of just a handful of fundamentals
is so incredibly valuable.
Another example of that would be Bill Gurley,
who's a spectacularly successful venture capitalist
and famous mostly — well, I shouldn't say
mostly, but he's associated with Benchmark.
And he came from Wall Street, having developed
these different valuation models or at least
used all sorts of tools for establishing value,
and got to tech in Silicon Valley and saw
what you saw in Hollywood.
It's like, "Wow, people really aren't tracking
this stuff."
And being able to sort of retrofit those to
this new environment allowed him and his partners
to find some incredible opportunities.
David Maisel: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about Marvel.
How does Marvel enter the picture?
David Maisel: Well, what happened, and it
relates to CAA and Michael, is Michael did
not take the job with Universal.
We sold it to Seagram, to Edgar Bronfman.
And famously, Michael was supposed to run
it and ended up not getting the job, and it
was given to Ron Meyer, who was Michael's
partner at CAA.
It was somewhat Shakespearean because Michael
and Ron were so close.
And perhaps — the papers say Michael might
have over-asked for what he wanted from Edgar
Bronfman.
But he hired Ron Meyer, who ended up spending
20 or 25 years, or 20 years, running Universal
Studios.
Everyone thought then that Michael was going
to stay at CAA, but then he decided to go
to Disney and be president of the Walt Disney
Company, with his friend Michael Eisner, who
was CEO.
That was cataclysmic in Hollywood.
I remember walking to a meeting that Michael
called early in the morning to announce this.
And then later that day, he called me to his
office and he invited me to join him at Disney.
I had a job offer from Ron Meyer to go to
Universal as well, and the third option was
to stay with the new owners of CAA, Kevin
and Ryan and others.
But I loved Disney.
I grew up loving the Disney parks.
We haven't talked about this, but when I graduated
from business school, the job offer I turned
down when I went to BCG was for the Walt Disney
Company, for strategic planning.
Tom Staggs, who ended up almost becoming CEO,
was in the waiting room with me at the time.
So I always had this interest in the Walt
Disney Company, and Michael was my guy, right?
And here's my idol now asking me to join him
in his new chapter.
So that turned out to be critical because
I then got to spend a couple years at Disney,
where it was like your dad was the president,
right?
So you had open access to everything.
Like I did at CAA, now I'm in a studio and
I'm seeing from a studio perspective all the
games that are played and how they view the
world.
And I was put in strategic planning and corporate
development, which was a powerhouse group
at Disney.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you should explain what
corporate development does.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Kind of like, you couldn't script
this movie better, in a way.
David Maisel: Corporate development at Disney
was — Michael Eisner had this group of people
that controlled strategy and every major move
under him, and they would work with division
heads.
Essentially, it was his way to centralize
major decisions at Disney and sort of control
those decisions.
I was put in an office next to Kevin Mayer,
who ended up almost becoming CEO, Tom Staggs,
who I mentioned.
So we would go to meetings with Michael Eisner
and Michael Ovitz, and I was Michael Ovitz's
guy, they were Michael Eisner's guys, and
we'd come back and we'd all get our phone
calls and it was just a crazy fun time.
They just bought ABC, and I remember Michael
Eisner saying, and Ovitz, "David, what are
you interested in?"
And I said, "Well, sports, and ESPN is sort
of cool.
I'll help out ABC."
And because of that, I was the liaison on
corporate development with Bob Iger, who was
the president of that division at the time,
and Steve Burke, who was his number two guy,
who became the head of Universal, Comcast
later on.
So I was so fortunate to be exposed to so
much in a two-year period, Tim — good and
bad — about what happens at a studio like
Disney.
That's one of the things my job was, was to
recommend acquisitions.
And the three thread with Marvel, I recommended
— I don't even think this is public, so
this is breaking news.
I recommended that Disney buy Marvel, back
in like '96, '97, right?
At the time, it was no more than a hundred
million dollars.
And I remember getting kicked out of the room,
basically, because one of the first things
that Michael Eisner and the other people in
the room saw was that there was no theme park
rights available east of the Mississippi River,
because that was a deal that Ron Perelman
had given to Universal.
And because of that, I sort of was not gently
told that this was a stupid idea.
Thankfully —
Tim Ferriss: What year was this roughly?
David Maisel: '96, '97.
Tim Ferriss: '96, '97.
Yeah, I'm also thinking of the kind of state
of the art, at the time, CGI, what was possible,
what was not possible.
In your mind, what was the selling or value
proposition at that time —
David Maisel: For Marvel.
Tim Ferriss: — for the recommendation?
What were the bullet points in the recommendation
for that acquisition?
David Maisel: The same as what I told Bob
Iger 14 years later when I actually sold him
Marvel for, on paper, four billion.
Tim Ferriss: You're like, "Let me just pull
this up from 14 years ago."
David Maisel: No, but to Bob's credit, Bob
wasn't the decision-maker in that earlier
meeting.
Tim Ferriss: Right, right.
David Maisel: He probably would not have even
been in the room because he was running ABC
at the time.
But he remembered that and I remembered it.
Okay, so separate from the movies that Disney
is very good at thinking about their customer,
and they're very strong with all of us as
babies, right?
And we all love Disney.
And then normally, guys start not liking Disney
when they're early teenagers, right?
It's not cool anymore.
Traditionally, that happens as well with females
at a later age, but at some point, you lose
interest in what you loved as a kid, and then
it comes back when you're a young parent,
right, and you have your own kids.
So there was a huge gap, especially with guys
between age 12 and age whenever they have
kids that Marvel was very strong with, right?
So it just mapped on that.
I don't even know if I was able to even get
to that point in this meeting, but it mapped
on that in that hole tremendously well, and
that was the driver at the time.
And then obviously, all the stuff you could
do with the Marvel characters, and I was starting
to dream then about Marvel films in a bigger
way.
But that idea came to me actually later, a
few years later.
So it was driven more by the gap in the lifetime
cycle of a Disney customer.
Tim Ferriss: That makes sense.
So you make the pitch, you are very unceremoniously
ejected from the meeting.
David Maisel: Yes.
Which happened to me a lot, by the way.
It happened many times.
Tim Ferriss: And at that point, they're like,
"Yeah, great idea, kid.
Not for right now, not for here."
And how does Marvel —
David Maisel: I'm not sure they said, "Great
idea."
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right.
So how does Marvel then boomerang and come
back to you?
David Maisel: Yeah, so Michael got fired,
by his best friend, from Disney in '97, '98.
And there, to make a long story short, he
again asked me to join him in this next venture
of his career.
That lasted a couple years, during which he
bought a Broadway company and I was able to
produce a show called Fosse and exercise my
first direct creative project, this Broadway
show, which did very well and we won the Tony
Award for best musical.
So it gave me some confidence, which is relevant
for what happens with Marvel later on.
And then I chased some internet money from
'99 to 2001.
A very famous investment banker, very well
known in Hollywood named Joe Ravitch, who
was at Goldman Sachs at the time, set me up
with a John Malone company, and I lived in
London and Amsterdam for two years, which
was great and also scary because the dotcom
crash happened in the early 2000s.
And then I came back to L.A. and I was ready
to get back into traditional business.
I went to work with Ari Emanuel and Patrick
Whitesell, who was a guy, a great agent, who
had an office next to me at CAA, and they
had just started Endeavor, what is now William
Morris Endeavor, this huge company.
And they offered me my first real payday to
work for them for two years.
The reason that's relevant is, besides Ari
and Patrick being amazing guys and shows you
how small this town is and they still run
that company, I knew I never wanted to be
an agent long term.
So when that two years started coming —
Tim Ferriss: Why is that?
David Maisel: It wasn't intriguing to me.
In an agency, like in a consulting firm or
a law firm, there was a role for someone like
me that was a wild card for a period of time,
but the real power and money came if you represented
clients and you could show that you're bringing
in direct revenues, and that wasn't what I
did.
And I also had my own entrepreneurial desires,
and it was in 2003 when I knew I had a couple
months left to go with Endeavor, that I sat
down for a weekend and figured out what has
become Marvel Studios and started that path
in my life.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
I'm going to inflict something horrible on
my audience, but I can't help myself.
So this is going to be one of those dun dun
dun, like cliffhangers on page 22 of a comic
book.
So Marvel, we're going to come back to Marvel.
But I have to very selfishly ask you about
your side path into Broadway and theater.
David Maisel: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: I say selfish because this, I
don't think, is known.
I don't think I've mentioned this anywhere.
So this is a first also that I have, over
the last few years, become one of the larger
investors in a theater production, and it's
the first time I've ever become involved with
that.
They did a run in Pennsylvania, their first
commercial run, and now they're going to be
opening a much larger production in Chicago
in the next few weeks, in fact, as of the
time of this recording.
For people who want to check it out, personalitymusical.com.
That's the story of Lloyd Price.
And if you don't know that name, you should
know the name.
It's pretty bananas how many cultural sort
of milestones this man touched.
In any case, it seems like a very tough business.
Even the deal structures have all sorts of
terms that I had never heard before in my
life.
It's very different from, say, early stage
tech investing on a multitude of levels, and
yet it seems like a beautiful, powerful vehicle
and art form in so many respects.
What would you say were key decisions or events
that informed the success of Fosse?
David Maisel: I think personal passion in
everything that I've done, when I look back
at it, I get very focused on whatever project
I'm working on, and I think I do better if
I really love it.
And theater and the excitement of live theater,
which you're now experiencing, which is so
cool with that project, however it works out,
is really indescribably hard to replicate.
It's a little bit like a live action film
shoot, but more unpredictable.
There's an audience there.
It's an animal of its own.
So that was number one.
Number two, I enjoy, I guess, telling stories
that have some sort of meaning to me and relevance.
And this was Bob Fosse, who was a very complicated
man.
Arguably one of our best choreographers in
America, ever, and probably one of the best
ever on Broadway.
And there's a movie called All That Jazz,
which I will recommend to everyone to watch
if they haven't seen it, with Roy Scheider
and Jessica Lange, which he directed, which
is really weird.
Biographical story about himself, because
he predicts his own death.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
David Maisel: He also was a great film director.
He won the Academy Award for best picture,
I think for Cabaret.
And when I learned about this guy's life and
saw that he died of whatever substance abuse,
and womanizing, his lifestyle, and had a very
tragic end, I thought that was a really interesting
story to tell.
And then third, he was known for his sensuality
of his dance.
It was like, whoa, I had never seen anything
like that.
So the ingredients made me believe that telling
this guy's life story through dance, through
his own dances could be a really cool Broadway
project.
I never thought we'd win the Tony for best
musical, because we had no dialogue in the
show.
It was literally all his dances and the different
phases of his life.
The other part I'd say is, and it's sort of
similar, I'm not afraid to use creative end
business in a decision.
A lot of people in Broadway or any place in
entertainment are so afraid of that because
your title is "Suit" if you talk about profits,
and if you want to be creative, you have to
ignore that and be above all that.
So the creative mystique is so subjective
that people have.
In most cases, there's not real accountability
unless you actually draw something or write
it yourself.
But I knew that a story, a dance musical,
would be very inexpensive, both its original
setup costs — the set itself, it's just
basically a black stage and two prosceniums.
The dancers are — there's no star.
Tim Ferriss: What was that term you used?
The blank stage and then —
David Maisel: I think it's proscenium.
It's like the arches in a theater.
I hope I'm saying that —
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
David Maisel: — correctly.
But we had —
Tim Ferriss: I got the image though.
David Maisel: Yeah, I think it was like $3
million to set up our set, right?
Which some musicals are way higher.
And then the writing cost of the show was
really low because it was 32 amazing dancers,
but no superstars.
So it was also a show that was easy to tour,
like you're doing with your show.
So I understood the economics of Broadway,
and this was a chance — the company that
Michael had bought was technically, basically
bankrupt, so we didn't have a lot of money
to spend on a show or market it.
So out of all the stuff we could do, I saw
that the company owned the rights to this
project, and I picked that one for us to focus
on.
So I was producing that at night and running
the company during the day for about two years.
Tim Ferriss: So for people who don't know,
and wink, wink, might even be me, I'm sure
there are others out there, the word "producer"
gets used in all sorts of contexts in movies,
in TV, in theater.
What does it look like for you at the time
to have been producing at night?
What were you focused on?
David Maisel: There's not accountability in
general in entertainment, and titles can mean
nothing or everything, right?
So I'm glad you clarified that.
I don't know what the name is for what I do,
but I've been lucky enough with Fosse, with
Marvel, with my projects post-Marvel to conceive
of the idea, basically, or see something like
Marvel that exists that has some legacy, or
Fosse, rights of — and to envision.
I guess the first step is vision what the
project could be.
Something that perhaps other people hadn't
seen.
And then when I produce, it's literally probably
not liked by many people, but it's micromanaging
all the various relevant major creative decisions
or business decisions, which might include
bringing in huge creative talent, which I
did on Fosse.
I brought in his ex-lover, Anne Reinking,
to direct, who had a lot of the dances in
her head.
And I was dealing with Gwen Verdon, his ex-wife,
and his daughter, Nicole Fosse.
But it's very — I like to define it there's
no Fosse musical if I don't make it, and there's
no MCU or Avengers if I don't go to Marvel.
So it's having the vision and then going there
and making it happen with whatever dials I
need to turn, creatively or business or political
or financing, to get it done.
Tim Ferriss: Just very quickly, we're going
to hone in on this, but MCU, just for people
who may not have that acronym, just if you
could just say what that is.
And then looking back at your experience with
Fosse, is there anything that you wish you
had known then that you know now, anything
you would've done slightly differently, perhaps?
Those are the —
David Maisel: With Fosse, I was blessed.
We had our out of town tryouts and then we
went to New York and we won the Tony.
It doesn't get much better than that for a
show, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
David Maisel: And I'm trying to think what
would be done differently with that.
We were able to sell that company, because
of Fosse's success, to Bob Sillerman at the
time.
And I remember the investment banker that
worked for me was a guy named Steve Bannon,
which was odd, but at the time, he had just
come from Goldman Sachs and I only knew him
as —
Tim Ferriss: What a polymath.
David Maisel: Yeah, he did a great job as
my banker and got the company sold.
When his name popped up later on in my life,
I was, "Whoa, is that the same person?"
and it was.
So that was sort of funny.
Tim Ferriss: That's so wild.
David Maisel: I know.
Crazy stories.
But later on, if we want to circle back to
it, I also produced the Spider-Man musical
on Broadway, which famously lost like 50 or
60 million.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to say, cost a little
more than three million to put the set together.
David Maisel: Now, Marvel had no capital in
it, and we had, I think, 10 percent of gross
ticket sales.
So we ended up making a significant profit
from that production.
And it was fantastic to work with Bono and
Edge from U2.
So there's a whole different animal, the Spider-Man
musical, but I was involved with that as well.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Well, let's hit it straight down
the fairway between these two poles.
And just before we move on, since I promised
folks, MCU, what does that stand for?
David Maisel: Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
And then we do the Wayne's World, we go back
in time and you know have a few months left
in working with, if I'm remembering correctly,
Ari and Patrick.
David Maisel: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And somewhere in the next few
months, some of the ideas related to Marvel
start to percolate.
What does that look like?
David Maisel: It actually happened, I remember
specifically, it was in October, November
of 2003 when I think my stint with Endeavor
was going to finish at the end of that calendar
year.
And since that story about the discussion
with Disney to potentially buy Marvel, Marvel
went bankrupt in 1999, and it had gotten through
a fight between Ron Perelman, Carl Icahn,
and Ike Perlmutter.
And Ike Perlmutter successfully got it for
$30 million or $50 million out of bankruptcy.
And it had been a public company for a couple
years post that, and achieved like a 200 million
valuation, and I was an investor in the stock.
So I watched as the first X-Men movie came
out, Spider-Man, of course, right?
And the stock had sort of stopped at a $200
million valuation.
I took out some old-fashioned paper and I
thought to myself, "Okay, what will my next
path be?"
I could potentially stay at Endeavor and William
Morris for the reasons we talked about.
It was just Endeavor at the time.
I decided not to do that.
Which I think Ari is really happy about because
he very much wanted to buy William Morris
even back then, and I was telling him all
the reasons not to.
So I think he was very happy that he didn't
have to listen to those anymore, and he's
done so well with that acquisition.
So it worked out really good for both of us.
I had another path, which was I could go to
one of the studios and try to work my way
up to be chairman of a studio, which is the
only position I saw where you could be both
creative and business.
Those jobs were what I really wanted, chairman
of a studio, because you greenlight movies,
that's the ultimate power, you decide what
gets made, and then you can influence that
on every one of those dials that I mentioned,
creative or business.
And it was the only place where I saw that
that really merged together.
Some producers had sort of power, but not
as much as a studio chairman.
So I thought about that path, Tim, and I realized
I didn't like it.
It wasn't like a law firm or McKinsey, which
is somewhat of a meritocracy.
Not totally, but at least logically you should
proceed if you deliver results.
I don't know what the formula is to become
studio chairman.
It's just one person selected every 10 years.
They're all in their 60s or 70s.
And I knew it would be a fool's gamble for
me to do that.
So then I'm sitting there with this crazy
thought of I'll create my own studio.
Then, by definition, I'm in charge of that
studio, right?
And my business, I thought too, it has to
be something I'm really interested in.
It has to have something that could really
be a sustainable, good business, because I
needed —
Tim Ferriss: Can I ask you a dumb question
just as an interjection?
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Because I feel like it's my job
to do that.
I just realized, as you're talking, I have
heard and used this term "studio" myself many
times, and I don't actually know exactly what
it means to be a studio.
David Maisel: Yeah, good question.
Tim Ferriss: Do they raise money and fund
production and then external production companies
and teams kind of take that money and run
with it?
How much is internal versus external?
If you started your own studio, what would
that entail?
David Maisel: So what a studio should mean
is that you bring all the elements to the
table.
You have the money, you have the properties,
you have people that either make the films
or hire producers.
Tim Ferriss: Properties meaning the intellectual
property.
David Maisel: Exactly.
You either make the movies yourself or you
internal producers or you hire other producers
to do it.
And then you market and distribute the films,
which costs as much as making the movies for
a major picture.
So at the time, there was six studios, Universal,
Disney, Fox, and so on, Sony, and they made
all the movies.
So every IP holder then and even now would
license their properties to these studios.
So Spider-Man was famously licensed to Sony.
Sony would make the decision when there's
a movie, how much they're going to spend,
creatively what it was going to be, and market
and distribute that movie and keep the vast,
not the majority, but like 95 percent plus
of profits.
So an IP holder like Marvel would only get
a piece of the money and they'd have script
notes, like certain rights, but nothing very
heavy.
Like you couldn't make Peter Parker do some
crazy job that wasn't relevant to the comics
or something like that.
And then normally, ancillaries, like toys,
would be split between the studio and the
rights holder.
So the way Marvel got to a $200 million valuation
was off the toys of Spider-Man, or the toys
of Hulk, or the toys of X-Men.
Very little money from the movies.
I was frustrated with that as an investor.
I didn't think it was a good model to grow
enterprise value.
So I was very focused on Marvel right away.
So luckily, I didn't have to look at my second
choice.
I knew I was personally interested in it.
And then I had this hypothesis, or model,
at the time, which was I knew how bad the
first movie business was.
You spend, in this case, a hundred million
dollars on something, you hope people show
up.
Yeah, research can help you a little bit,
but very little.
It's pretty random.
Stars at the time could maybe open the movie.
But it's a horrible, not a horrible, but a
pretty bad business.
But the sequel business was amazing because
statistically, you could predict the revenues
plus or minus something, and you could manage
your profit margin, not whether you made profits.
So the big idea I had, which was now is called
the Universe, was what if after the first
movie, every movie after that was a sequel
or a quasi-sequel, which required all the
characters, or a lot of the characters, to
show up in multiple movies?
That led me, again, to Marvel because I knew
about the vast universe of characters, and
that this would be a perfect way, in my mind,
to make every movie after the first one a
sequel, or a quasi-sequel.
So it came up over 24, 48 hours that weekend,
the whole thing.
Tim Ferriss: Were you sitting in an ashram?
Were you flying on airplanes?
Were you having —
David Maisel: No, no, no.
I was —
Tim Ferriss: — endoscopy?
What was going on?
David Maisel: It was very boring, sweatpants
sitting in my rental apartment across from
the park near Fairfax where I still have my
studio.
Same building.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so you're capturing all
this on a yellow notepad or —
David Maisel: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: — in your laptop or wherever.
Then what?
So it's great idea.
I could see how this works.
David Maisel: That was the good news.
The bad news was I didn't know anyone at Marvel.
I knew Marvel had licensed a lot of its properties
like Spider-Man, X-Men.
I didn't know how many that they had licensed
beyond that.
I had never made a movie before in my life.
So there's a lot of things that were obstacles.
And in the next month or two, I got an introduction
to a man named Avi Arad and Ike Perlmutter
who were the two guys running Marvel, the
public company at the time.
Tim Ferriss: How did you get that introduction?
This is not trivial.
David Maisel: Yeah.
It's shows you how small this town is.
My lawyer who negotiated my deal with Ari
Emanuel in Endeavor was a man named Josh Grode,
who was also Avi Arad's lawyer at the time.
And I told my lawyer my interest and he said,
"Oh, I can introduce you to Avi."
Now, to show you how this town is really small,
Josh is now the CEO and president of Legendary
Entertainment, which is a big mini studio
owned by, a lot, by the Chinese.
And so he's become his own studio chairman
and pretty powerful company with the King
Kong movies and other things like that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Maisel: So you mentioned studio.
At the time, Avi was in charge of what was
called Marvel Studios, but it was really a
small shop of giving script notes to license
movies.
Avi successfully saw the potential of Marvel
films and started licensing the movies post
the bankruptcy.
Ike and Avi had known each other for many
years, and Avi started as a toy creator and
he did the original license deal with Spider-Man.
He did the original license deal with Fox
for X-Men, and that's what the route that
Marvel was on at the time was licensing these
movies and continuing to license their films.
Ike owned, I think, 40 or 50 percent of Marvel
at the time, even though it was a public company,
and he was in charge of everything.
Tim Ferriss: How uncommon is that?
That seems like a gigantic equity position.
David Maisel: It was, yeah, because he got
it out of company bankruptcy.
He got out of bankruptcy and he kept it.
And so Ike was the person I really needed
to pitch, and I pitched him at Mar-a-Lago
in November of 2003, and I remember that flying
to Palm Beach and having lunch there, and
Trump came by, was close with Ike.
They're still very close.
And I was introduced to Trump, and Trump said
something about he had a TV show starting
soon, which turned out to be The Apprentice,
and he was excited about that.
That's all I remember from that conversation.
And I pitched Ike in the same way I pitched
Ovitz and Ike did not see and agree that they
should do their own films right away, but
he was open-minded enough to offer me a job
and give me a lot of stock options at market
and give me a chance to fight for it internally.
And Ike, he is now, I think, the largest individual
shareholder of Disney.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
You can fight this fight.
I don't necessarily agree with all of it up
front, but yeah, you'll have your day in court,
so to speak.
David Maisel: Exactly.
That was it.
Tim Ferriss: And what then proceeds to happen
from there?
David Maisel: I had one other job that I was
looking at, which I'm only going to raise,
and I've never told this publicly because
of your question about theater, but I got
a phone call in the fall of 2003 from a very
high-pitched voice who said, "Hi, this is
Michael Jackson."
And he went on to say that he had seen Fosse
on Broadway and loved the show, and it was
a personal call.
I don't know how he got my phone number and
I thought it was fake.
And he said, "I want you to tell my life story
through my music videos."
And I was like, "Whoa."
And that turned into a one or two month set
of discussions with Michael about doing a
50/50 deal where I'd have — he put in all
his music videos and all the IP.
I'd be able to produce it.
And we both had vetoes on each other.
And I got him to agree that he would perform,
randomly once every couple months, Thriller.
So you'd go to the Broadway show and you'd
see Michael Jackson actually perform — be
like a lottery.
And Josh Grode was my lawyer on that.
So I have the deal agreement.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to say that'd be
tricky to figure out from the legal perspective.
David Maisel: But he was very smart.
I've got to tell you, he was very smart business
person.
And then I wasn't really, seriously, I was
going to carve that out of my Marvel deal,
and I think Marvel was going to let me do
that.
And then I saw Michael get arrested, and so
I let that fizzle right at that period of
time, but it was like the other thing that
I was looking at.
And then third, Hef was circling me about
potentially helping him run Playboy at the
time, which was an IP company, but Marvel
was the part where my focus was the highest.
And I started right away basically two weeks
after that meeting with Ike at the end of
2003.
Tim Ferriss: In title, what was your job?
David Maisel: My title was President of what
was then called Marvel Studios, which wasn't
a studio.
We didn't bring any money.
We didn't have distribution in marketing.
We weren't making the movies, but it was called
Marvel Studios from a title point of view.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So he put you in the position where you could,
at least without having to lily pad hop around
the company, implement what you'd been discussing?
David Maisel: Yeah, it was 2004.
So this part we're going to get into, which
I'm happy to do.
Like you said in the beginning, I've never
talked through in this way and I've also not
done press of any significant note in the
past 10 years.
So a large amount of this is still coming
to light.
And so some things people might know and some
things they might not.
But in 2004, we had a very small office, on
Santa Monica Boulevard.
I think Ike, he was definitely interested
in making more money from entertainment.
And so my job was really how can we make more
money without taking any significant risk?
Had a career of bankruptcy type of companies,
Remington and now Marvel, and those people
are not ones that take big capital risk on
big grandiose visions.
And the board of directors was a bunch of
ex-bankruptcy guys, basically.
And Sid Ganis, I remember, who was the president
of the Academy of Motion Pictures, was the
one Hollywood person there.
And so I would argue for the studio, in the
board meetings and was basically told to be
quiet, maybe not those words.
My last name wasn't Spielberg and not to bring
it up again unless Marvel had no risk.
Not little risk, but no risk.
And so —
Tim Ferriss: Conjure me this, Spielberg.
David Maisel: And what was important at the
time is I asked the board to at least give
me six months.
And what that meant is not to license anymore
movies.
They were about to license Captain America
and Thor to two major studios, I think it
was Warner Bros. and Sony.
And Thor specifically was very close to being
licensed.
And I basically had to hold my breath in the
board meeting and say, "If you do that, I
can't do anything.
I need at least those characters to put together
something that somebody would finance as a
slate."
And they gave me that six-month time.
And so during 2004, I put on my MBA hat, I
spent a lot of time in New York, and was able
to raise the financing that we needed — was
about a half a billion dollars of what turned
out to be, I mean, it sounds crazy to say,
but for those that are interested, it was
no risk.
It was non-recourse.
Marvel never had to pay it back in no collateral.
Tim Ferriss: So, two things, how do you sell?
How do you pitch that and then how do you
structure that?
David Maisel: The structuring, it's related,
it was this idea of the universe, again, not
a word that we used at the time, but it was
the vision of intermixing all the characters.
First to my board, the argument, was if we
own our own studio, it means we get the full
financial upside that they understood very
well.
Number two, we decide on greenlight when the
movies get made that they also understood
because they only sold toys really at the
time, and the toys were contingent on a movie,
which they then control the timing.
Now when you're doing a public company and
you're giving guidance every year, how can
you give guidance if you don't even know what
movies are going to get made?
And so controlling greenlight was important,
full creative control.
I felt that people like myself and Kevin Feige
eventually, because we care about the movies,
would make better movies for the fans.
I'm not sure my board really heard that point
or really understood it, given that neither
Kevin or I had ever made a movie ourselves,
like I said.
And then fourth, we would keep all the ancillaries
as well, the toys and video games.
So there was a lot of reasons for this to
happen.
The challenge of not having risk is normally
insurmountable.
Thank God again for timing.
Like we talked about, the bond bubble of 2004
was happening, so it was a time where there
was loans being made that shouldn't have been
made.
And a lot of people were enamored with Hollywood
as they get enamored every few years.
And so I was able to pitch that, give me four
at bats, and if one of them hits, then every
movie's a sequel after that.
And when they ran their models, they were
able to get it past their investment committee
to the point where there was no equity component.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
All right.
Just so I understand, there are many ways
to raise financing.
So are we talking about banks?
Are we talking about if so, what types of
banks are we talking about?
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Who are the people you were pitching
to agree to these terms and provide the financing?
David Maisel: Pitched a lot of different entities,
but turned out to be Merrill Lynch who took
the gamble with us and helped structure it,
then they offloaded, and it was structured,
as I mentioned, as pure debt.
So very low interest rate.
And the only collateral were the film rights
to 10 Marvel characters of which we could
make for the movies.
And a lot of people misunderstand that they
think we pledged 10 of our characters as collateral.
It wasn't that at all because in the worst
case scenario, it only got collected if we
lost money on those first four movies.
And then those six characters, we owned all
the rights besides film.
And if a film was ever made by the bank, whoever
collected this collateral, we got the same
license fee that we get if we just license
it that day to a party.
So there was no opportunity cost.
Tim Ferriss: So that's how you would justify
it to your board of directors?
David Maisel: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Also?
David Maisel: Right, exactly.
And not only that —
Tim Ferriss: Worst case, we get what we would've
gotten doing our current model?
David Maisel: And actually even better because
we were able to get five percent of a hundred
percent revenues as a producer fee.
So even if the film lost money, we were making
10 to 20 million, and the bank let us keep
all of the non film revenues, like toys and
video games in a different waterfall.
So even if the four at bats lost, we were
making 25 million per movie, and that's a
hundred million dollars, and the whole company
was worth 200.
So it was not a deal that the board could
say no to, but they also got enthusiastic
about it by the end of 2004.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So were there any hurdles with the board,
or was it just so clearly delivering on the
request of zero risk that there was just no
defensible position they could take that would
object to this?
David Maisel: Yeah, eventually when the financing
came together.
But it's important for Marvel fans to realize
that it was tender at the time.
If we were not able to raise riskless capital
like that, the MCU might never have occurred.
Or if I got there six months later and those
other movies were licensed, it would've been
too late, anyways.
The idea, by the way, of Marvel or any IP
holder making their own hundred million dollar-plus
movie was revolutionary.
Like nobody to this day, I'm only aware of
Marvel and Angry Birds who's done that, and
Angry Birds I was part of after I left.
So it was a crazy idea, Tim.
And to Ike's credit, he knew he did give me
that audience.
He sent me an email that I have behind me
recently thanking me for my tenacity and basically
said — can I actually read it?
One second.
"This was after Avengers: Endgame in 2019.
David, the movie was a terrific accomplishment,
and we know that it all started with you,
your vision, and your tenacity and pushing
to achieve that vision."
The word tenacity is about those hurdles you
just mentioned, right?
It was tough.
I mean, that was a huge hurdle to get over
having the correct financing that would work.
I have never said this publicly.
I could have showed up in the boardroom and
given up half the equity and the same terms
for the other 50 percent of the money, and
that would've been easier to structure, and
perhaps my board would not have cared.
Half is better than nothing of the movie,
and I was very greedy.
I wanted Marvel to keep a hundred percent
of the upside because also I was one of the
largest individual owners at that time with
my stock options.
And so I was very tenacious with Ike, but
I was also very tenacious with Merrill Lynch
that we keep a hundred percent of the upside
and no deal is easy.
They tried to renegotiate and make us put
up a third of the budget some other way.
I was fortunate, I guess, to be able to convince
them not to do that at the end.
So it was very prepared.
Tim Ferriss: And this was renegotiating years
later after they had signed the dotted line,
or this was mid-process?
David Maisel: Yeah, we closed.
We probably came to agreement in the fall
of '04 and closed it in the spring of '05.
And things always get renegotiated until they're
closed.
It's the best way to put it.
Yeah.
Now all those guys, it turned out to be one
of their best loans they ever made, obviously.
And I'm friends with a lot of those bankers
still.
It was an interesting time, but that was only
one of the things, because even with the money
that came in, we still needed a distribution
deal with a studio.
All that money was contingent on a major studio
putting up 150 million bucks to market the
right.
Tim Ferriss: Before we get there, just a very
quick question.
Keeping in mind I'm slow-moving from Long
Island.
David Maisel: No worries.
Tim Ferriss: Takes me a minute or two.
So I'm thinking of the numbers here.
Company is worth, as a publicly traded company,
yeah, I think you said 200 million, right?
200 million market cap.
You're raising 500 million.
To do that, I would love to know what the
most important exhibits were and how the licensed
films like X-Men and Spider-Man fit into that,
if at all, right?
Because otherwise it strikes me that it would
be perhaps based on industry comps, but it
would be considered potentially very speculative.
David Maisel: I think a lot of people are
now looking and learning that Marvel Studios
was a relay race.
Stan Lee and the original comic creators created
the characters, and then the baton went to
Ike and Avi and Avi specifically doing these
license deals, and Ike supported him.
And then the baton in 2003 went to me, and
then we can get to later on, I passed the
baton to Kevin Feige in 2010, and he's still
running the studio.
If I didn't have the numbers of X-Men and
Spider-Man to point to and run scenarios to
my board internally and to the bank that what
if we just do half of those numbers or two-thirds
of those numbers for their stress case scenarios?
Yeah, I mean, they never ran a stress case
scenario at doing a third of those numbers.
If they did, we would've failed.
So they wanted this deal to happen.
And there's incentives.
We go back to the street smarts of Mike Ovitz,
right?
What does Merrill want out of this?
What does the bank want?
Well, they got, I think, a three percent success
fee with this deal, and they held the debt
for all of probably a half hour until they
flipped it to somebody else.
So there was incentives for everyone to get
this deal done.
And that was important to figure out.
Tim Ferriss: Dumb question, who's paying the
three percent?
David Maisel: It comes out of the facility.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Yeah.
Need you to expand on that.
David Maisel: So I've raised 525 million and
three percent of that, about 17 million —
Tim Ferriss: I see.
David Maisel: — went to Merrill Lynch right
away.
Tim Ferriss: And who are they raising it from?
I'm just wondering if they're taking it out
of one pocket and sticking it in the other
—
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — what that means.
David Maisel: A lot of times, and I learned
this in real time doing this, we really didn't
have a banker helping us on this deal too
much.
And so it was a man named John Turitzin, who
was the general counsel of Marvel, and who
is important to mention because he was the
closest person and still is to Ike.
And he kept my head in the game, and he helped
me get through this process.
And many times, I thought of quitting and
Ike probably thought about firing me.
I know he talked us both off the ledge many
times.
So if it wasn't for John, there's no Marvel
Studios either.
I'm either fired or I quit and probably fired.
But I guess it's a pretty detailed thing,
but I was very greedy.
I wanted the interest rate to be lower, and
we got it insured by a company called the
MPAC, most of the debt.
So it became AAA debt, which is then easy
to sell to pensions and easy to sell to individual
investors.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
David Maisel: Yeah.
So Merrill turned around and it was packaged
with AAA, and they were able to resell it.
David Maisel: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sorry to belabor this point.
Again, my podcast is basically my continuing
education for Tim Ferriss program.
So coming out of the facility is Merrill,
are they basically reselling it and then taking
their three percent after they have resold
it?
I guess, I'm just trying to figure out where
the success fee, how it comes out of the facility.
David Maisel: I think they took risk because
at the time the deal closes, they're obligated
to put up the 525.
So they got their success fee, I think, right
at that time.
And then they resell most of it to other people
pretty immediately.
So I don't know.
I'm trying to remember back, this was 2003,
2004, 2005, but they had risk when the deal
closed for, I don't know if it was for half
hour or for one day or for two days, but they
had risk for a period of time before they
resold all that.
And that's when they get their success fee
once the money's guaranteed us.
Tim Ferriss: Is one division of Merrill Lynch
paying another division the 17 million or
whatever it adds —
David Maisel: Oh, that's a good question.
No.
If they got stuck with the whole loan, then
they're sort of paying themselves, I guess.
Yeah, I didn't think about it that way.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
What a world.
David Maisel: I'm not sure there was a risk
of that when it happened, because most of
it was insured.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
This is a world that is largely foreign to
me.
But let's come back to, as you mentioned,
the other very, very critical kind of leg
on the stool, which is a distribution deal.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How did you go about securing
that?
How did you go about trying to pick, is all
distribution more or less the same thing and
it's just a different marquee name on the
same function and they kind of all performed
the same way?
How did you go about navigating that?
David Maisel: Well, it was easy because we
didn't have a choice to pick.
Nobody wanted to be our partner.
So at the end of the day, only one person
said yes, which was Paramount, part of Viacom.
But the way we got there, I mean, no, at the
time, this is really important.
In 2003, 2004, 2005, Marvel wasn't the Marvel
it is today.
So everyone that's listening, it's many people
probably don't remember that Marvel wasn't
this huge thing that it's been the past 15
years.
And in Hollywood, I mean, if it was, by the
way, I never would've gotten this opportunity.
So Disney or somebody else could have bought
Marvel for 500 million much earlier if they
wanted to.
And so the studios, nobody wanted to distribute
these movies.
And it wasn't just Sony.
It was Universal and others, we had obstacles.
Now we wanted great terms, but nobody really
believed in these properties.
And Iron Man, New Line, which is part of Warner
Bros., they had the rights for many, many
years and I think for seven or eight years
and never thought it was worthy to make into
a film, and they let the rights expire and
gave it back to us.
So it was a very different world.
So why Paramount?
When I was at Disney, I got to be friendly
with a guy named Rob Moore, who was one of
the senior people at the studio at Disney.
He was Vice Chairman of Paramount at this
time.
He was on his way to a Lakers game, and I
tackled him in the parking lot and just bugged
him enough because he didn't want to be late
to the basketball game that he agreed to.
Seriously, he agreed to have a meeting with
me.
And then Brad Gray was his boss, who Avi Arad
knew.
And so we sort of tag-teamed these two men
and convinced them that this was a good bet.
And to your point, we showed them that they
were the last money.
They put up the last 150 million.
They got the first 150 million back.
So the film only had to do a percentage of
X-Men for them to at least get their money
back.
Tim Ferriss: So they were sort of last in,
first out —
David Maisel: They were, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — in terms of preferences.
David Maisel: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
David Maisel: But even with that, nobody else
wanted to do it.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Aside from getting slide tackled
in the Lakers parking lot, what was it, do
you think, and maybe you already answered
this, and I just am too dense and it didn't
land.
What led them to say yes in contrast to all
the others who said no?
What did they see or how did you refine the
pitch that didn't exist in the other conversations?
David Maisel: I think they listened, and Rob
trusted me from our times at Disney.
He knew me pretty well, so the past relationship
helped.
And he knew I wasn't careless with my analysis
or my statements.
And so at least for Rob, I can't speak for
Brad, but for Rob, he understood.
And when he finally listened to where the
break even was for them, he saw it was a good
bet, right?
In the upside, he had distribution rights
to, I think five or 10 movies in the downside.
He basically broke even if the film didn't
do well.
There's a lot of other games.
Studios make money internally even on P&A.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just explain P&A?
David Maisel: Print and advertising.
So I remember Jeffrey Katzenberg had a distribution
deal with Paramount, and he was running DreamWorks
Animation and he basically coached me on what
terms I should ask for and mentored me on
that.
And so we had a deal that was really good.
There was no non-cash charges.
There was no overhead charge to us.
Tim Ferriss: What is a non-cash charge?
David Maisel: Yeah, that's a good question.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I understand the wording,
but I don't know what it is.
David Maisel: They would inflate the costs
that they got reimbursed.
So they would say they spent 150 million on
marketing, but 20 million of that's overhead
and another 10 million some odd costs, so
—
Tim Ferriss: It's shipping and handling for
infomercial products.
You're like, "How is shipping and handling
$17?"
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Yeah, extra handling, man.
Yeah, right.
Okay.
David Maisel: It actually was important because
it can eat up all your profits on a movie
if you get charged too much.
We had a 10 percent distribution fee, which
is really attractive as well.
I think George Lucas had the lowest I'm aware
of at six or seven percent for Star Wars.
Tim Ferriss: So how the hell did he get that?
I mean, that was also at the time.
It's easy for people to forget, but it's not
like that was the juggernaut franchise that
it is today.
I don't want to take us too far afield, but
wow.
Okay.
Got it.
So they say, all right, worst case we recoup
best case we have rights to these things you
claim will be as predictable or similarly
predictable to sequels.
David Maisel: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
David Maisel: And Tim, the part that I guess
with both the bankers and with Paramount is
I would strongly make the case creatively
for why I thought Iron Man would be a success
and why the MCU, which wasn't called at the
time, could be a success.
And then also Avi and Kevin would come into
these meetings with the bankers and with the
distribution partners to talk about their
experiences on those movies of X-Men and Spider-Man.
So we had the sexy halo effect of producers
on those movies, even though we weren't actually
full producers and all those things, especially
with the bankers were really important.
And with Rob and Paramount, I think it was
more the financial trade for them, but they
saw the success of Spider-Man with Sony and
hoped that they could get that upside, which
they did.
Tim Ferriss: So why Iron Man?
Right?
As you know, we've talked about this.
I love comics.
I have boxes and boxes and boxes of comic
books from my childhood, still cardboard-backed
and poly-bagged sitting in my parents' probably
garage being eaten by mice or something at
this point.
But there are a lot of characters to choose
from.
You have a lot of options.
Why Iron Man?
David Maisel: We didn't have that many options.
Again, so when we closed the financing, we
didn't have Iron Man.
We listed 10 characters, and those 10 characters
were led by Captain America, Thor, this thing
called Avengers, which people thought was
a British spy TV show.
And The Avengers weren't defined in our deal.
So it could be, as with the comics, different
characters in The Avengers, right?
So it was sort of a weird category of a property.
There was Black Panther in there.
There was Doctor Strange, but nobody cared
about those characters at all.
That people thought of Black Panther as a
terrorist group from the '60s.
Doctor Strange was a small comic.
I think we had Cloak and Dagger in there,
Shang-Chi, which finally made it as a movie,
Power Pack, that people don't know these names.
I mean, there weren't that many big names,
and I'm not sure we even put Thor in the beginning
because there was disagreement internally
whether Thor was even practical, given the
cost of Asgard.
And so for a while, we didn't know what the
first movie was going to be.
I was able to get the rights for Hulk back.
I mentioned Ron Meyer went to become chairman
of Universal from CAA earlier.
And so Ron, I knew very well, and I texted
him and asked him for a meeting, and they
had done the first Hulk movie with Ang Lee,
which was critically well received, but not
box office-wise.
And they were owned by GE at the time.
And I said, "Ron, are you ever going to make
a Hulk movie?"
And he said, "No, probably not."
And I said, "What about if I finance it and
you distribute it, I'll give you 10 percent?"
And he said, "Yes."
And so that's why we got the Hulk back into
the Marvel Universe.
And that's why the first Hulk movie was made
in 2008, because by making one film, we got
the rights back for Hulk in perpetuity and
at least as a supporting character.
And also, we were splitting toys 50/50 with
Universal, and that became way in our favor.
And Hulk Hands were our number one toy, so
we were thinking of Hulk potentially as the
first movie.
And then Iron Man came back and Kevin and
I were both really excited about Iron Man,
as was Avi Arad who was still at the studio.
He left in early 2006.
And so we zeroed in on that.
I don't know exactly why other people missed
it.
I think what we were excited about was the
man inside the suit.
We love the sexy suit of armor like most people
do, but Tony Stark is such a cool character.
And if you don't see Tony Stark, you don't
see how good the movie can be.
And so I think that was probably the breakthrough
for the three of us.
Tim Ferriss: I can't remember which film it
was from, but there's one of the Marvel films.
I think it was quite a bit later where there's
some disagreement, I want to say it's between
Thor and Stark.
And he's like, "Well, if we take that suit
off you, who are you?"
And he's like, "Billionaire, playboy…"
David Maisel: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God.
What a character.
Let's then walk into the next steps for Iron
Man.
Because I feel like this is such a, maybe
not make it or break it, but such a critical
project overall as a harbinger of things to
come perhaps, as a signal, as a proof-of-concept.
What were some of the key decisions or critical
moments in that development phase and then
moving into the theatrical release?
David Maisel: To give perspective on that,
we talked about how in 2004, 2005, it was
primarily raising the money and getting a
distribution partner in Paramount.
I was then promoted to vice chairman of the
studio in that period.
And in 2006, Avi left the studio in early
2006.
And then I was running the studio myself and
I promoted Kevin Feige, who was a young kid
that was helping Avi on script notes who I'd
gotten to know very well and admired him,
his creativity and his love of the comics.
I promoted him to be my president of production
and I was chairman of the studio and promoted
to that.
I also was fortunate to be promoted to office
of the CEO with Ike and John of the parent
company.
And so it's relevant because with those pieces
in place, we were able to focus solely on
making that film.
There was no more internal politics.
There wasn't these external things we needed
like financing or distribution deals.
We had that.
We had the rights back.
We had a clean structure in the company.
I promoted my ex-assistant into the creative
realm.
He became our number two guy creatively, Jeremy
Latcham.
We hired Louis D'Esposito and Victoria Alonso,
two amazing talents, early in that period
of time.
And all of us then focused on making this
movie.
And Jon Favreau was identified as the director
and Robert Downey as the actor, that was the
two big decisions.
Tim Ferriss: How did those two two happen?
How did those two end up happening?
David Maisel: A lot of people think of Jon
today for his Star Wars stuff and a lot of
visual effects, but at the time he was a lot
more known for Swingers and for those types
of films.
Tim Ferriss: People forget about Elf too.
David Maisel: Yeah.
And he was just coming off of Zathura and
we knew — we felt like we knew how to do
the comic book part of things, like the action
and the comic booky part of stuff.
But we also knew we didn't have a lot of money
to make the movie.
I could greenlight to $165 million, but I
told my board I'd make the film at a budget
that would allow it to break even at a percentage,
I think two-thirds of X-Men.
And so my budget for the film was about 100,
$105 million.
Now that's — sounds like a lot, but it wasn't.
I mean, Batman that year was 230 million.
And so that allowed us to have some action,
but not a lot.
So we knew we'd have an hour and 45 minutes
of Tony Stark in his workshop or talking to
Pepper Potts.
And Jon was great on those scenes and is great
on those scenes, and also getting the best
out of talent like Robert Downey.
I think that was something we all saw in Favreau.
Plus, he seemed very committed to it.
His career obviously has taken off in the
past 15 years tremendously, and he's shown
his talent in so many other ways.
And Robert Downey, I think, originally came
from John and Kevin.
They both were proponents for Robert as studio
chairman.
I had to give the final thumbs up and thumbs
down on that, but I agreed with them.
Knowing Tony Stark from the comics and Robert's
work, it wasn't obvious.
Robert had never had a box office success.
He had just been arrested a couple years earlier
for drugs and spent time in jail, so it's
not who you bet your company on.
And he came in and did a video audition, which
is also rare.
And I remember taking that recommendation
to Ike and the board and showing them that
video audition and they asked a lot of tough
questions, but they also agreed.
That was a key part.
I think with those two pieces in place, Kevin
and I were off to the races with Jon and Robert
to make this film.
Which is, I think this month, it's our 15th
anniversary of release.
Tim Ferriss: What were some of the biggest
challenges?
It could have been in production or in distribution
or in any facet of that experience.
David Maisel: What I just talked you through
was the biggest, Tim.
It was getting the job at Marvel, getting
the financing in place, convincing the board,
getting the distribution deal, getting the
rights back to Iron Man, getting the board
to agree with us on Robert Downey.
And getting the internal politics of Marvel,
like there are in every company, settled so
by that spring of 2006, two years before the
movie comes out, we have all those pieces
in place.
We didn't have an office.
We took the Mercedes-Benz dealership on Santa
Monica Boulevard.
Playboy had an office in the very top corner
and they were having financial difficulties.
And I sublet it from Hefner and put a Marvel
Studio sign outside that cost $10,000 and
we announced our presence and we just would
work there 18 hours a day.
We moved pre-production for a movie, which
is where all the planning gets done, right
there in that same floor, which is normally
never done with a studio, which was Kevin
and I.
But I guess there's another thing that people
should hear about is, I had this philosophy
that studios, Hollywood studios, were — had
this unnecessary layer of management called
studio executives who hire the producers.
So our model was, there's no studio executives.
We were the producers of the movie.
And so Kevin and I were technically studio
executives, but we were working on the film.
Kevin, every day.
Me with a significant chunk of my time because
I was also co-CEO, and we didn't have that
layer.
So we all, with Jon and Robert and all the
pre-production, were all together for months
planning out this film.
We had a pretty smooth ride, amazingly, from
that point on.
We took the Spruce Goose hangar by the ocean
where Howard Hughes had this huge wooden hangar
that he built the biggest airplane in the
world.
And that's appropriately where we filmed it
since Tony Stark is influenced by Howard Hughes.
And that was a big decision because we didn't
get tax incentives by being in California.
But it turned out to be great because we were
all so close and it became a set of people
that were really enthusiastic.
Gwyneth Paltrow joined.
That was a big win.
I think it was Bryan Lourd who called me and
said Gwyneth was interested.
And my God, to get an Academy Award-winning
actress like her was a dream.
So it all came together.
We had some disagreements at the end about
re-shoots, which cost some money.
But I was able to get Ike and the board to
approve the ones that we wanted to do.
Marketing was a tough challenge too, to get
Paramount to manage marketing because all
this stuff doesn't make any sense if nobody
goes to see the movie.
I think it was Katzenberg who told me to show
up at every meeting and that make sure we
get a good release date.
In retrospect, we chose May 2nd because nobody
else wanted it.
It was an early date.
People thought the summer started with Memorial
Day.
And so us going to May 2nd, now it's a great
date and Marvel has it every year.
But it turned out to be really good because
we had the first movie of the summer and Paramount
was — gave us that date.
They keep their best dates for their own movies,
so we were able to get a date they didn't
want.
It sounds weird to say things went smoothly
from that point on, but for those two years,
things went very smoothly.
Tim Ferriss: Let me rewind just a little bit
because I have some notes in front of me that
I want to fact check with you.
And you can't believe everything you read
on the internet, but this is Hollywood Reporter,
so you would hope that it is accurate.
Is it true that you had an early proof-of-concept
in the sense of changing Marvel's strategy
with a low-budget Iron Man animated film,
or maybe animatics?
Is that true?
David Maisel: Yeah, it is.
In 2004, while I was raising the money for
the theatrical films, I wanted to prove to
the board that we actually could produce something.
And so I was able to make a deal with Lionsgate,
Michael Burns and Jon Feltheimer who still
run Lionsgate, that we'd make $3 million direct-to-DVD
animated movies.
I think the budget was three to four million.
And they put up the money.
We at Marvel Studios produced it.
We hired a guy named Eric Rollman.
Tim Ferriss: For those who aren't watching
the video, that was air quotes in that example.
David Maisel: And then I remember they got
their three or four million back and we split
the money.
So we had no risk.
It was like a mini Marvel Studios type of
deal.
I forget the order.
We made a Doctor Strange one.
We made Iron Man.
We made Avengers.
We made a Hulk one.
And they all did pretty well.
And so they're still fun to watch.
And that was our chance to creatively be in
charge of a project and show the board that
we could do it.
Tim Ferriss: Incredible.
David Maisel: A lot of people don't point
that out, Tim.
You do good research.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I need to thank my team
also for finding this particular example.
I love finding these proof-of-concept moments
or talking as we have been also about structuring.
Because as you mentioned, I think in many
worlds, not just film, not just Hollywood,
there is almost a religious divide between
the people who are derisively called suits
and the people who are sometimes over-romanticized
as creatives.
And you can be a one-event athlete in that
sense that you stick really narrowly within
a lane and you can become world-class and
very successful doing that.
But in many cases, it's like the creatives
don't get to do what they would most want
to do unless things are structured by someone
who understands incentives and these various
provisions.
So I find your story so compelling for a lot
of reasons.
One of which is, you blend these capacities
in a very effective way because they could
be blended ineffectively, right?
David Maisel: No, and part of it, Tim, is
I think most people, because I haven't done
press, they view my role as very much the
financial structuring, the distribution deal,
the co-CEO role on Marvel, and less on the
creative side.
You know what?
In retrospect, in talking this through with
you, the biggest creative thing I've ever
done in my life was the first — that weekend
and having the vision for the MCU.
For having what became the Universe and just
intuitively believing these characters could
become a modern mythology for this world.
And that's a delusional belief I had at the
time, in retrospect.
I didn't realize the bar of this.
And then I had to put on the hat that I had
to do for each of the dominoes.
So if I went into my board and I just creatively
talked, they wouldn't have listened to me.
So I had to argue in their language about
finance and to the bankers about the financing
and to Paramount about their break-evens.
And politically structure a studio in terms
of personnel that I thought could do well.
And then to manage creative people like Jon
Favreau and Robert Downey and Kevin Feige,
my president of production.
Who, they all worked for me.
I was chairman of the studio.
But to get the best out of them, I learned
this from my time at CAA and Disney, it can't
be because you're their boss.
It's got to be because you give them the creative
freedom to explore and be careful about guardrails.
So a lot of people would say, "Oh, it was
my idea, I was studio chairman, to do Robert
Downey."
Rather than saying, "John and Kevin recommended
him."
I love that.
That's why you hire good people.
That's why I'm very proud of promoting Kevin
Feige.
A lot of people, I think, believe because
I haven't been doing press that Stan Lee or
Kevin created Marvel Studios.
And as we heard in the story, that that's
not the case.
The baton came to me and that was my legacy,
which I'm really proud of.
But I'm also really proud of identifying Kevin.
And I remember the conversation with Ike,
who had never met Kevin before, in 2006.
Ike's in New York and Kevin and I were in
L.A., "You need to hire somebody," when Avi
left.
I said, "No, Kevin can do it.
He can be my president in production."
When I sold the company to Disney, I told
the same thing to Iger that Kevin could run
it.
I'm his biggest fan in how he's done the films
the past 10 years and has become the most
respected creative producer in Hollywood.
And so part of managing creativity is knowing
when to exert yours and when to get the best
out from others.
I remember the biggest time I ever exerted
mine was early in 2006.
I think it was over Christmas holidays, I
got unhappy with the Iron Man script.
And the script at the time, Jeff Bridges is
Obadiah Stane, who, in the movie is the villain,
was actually working for The Mandarin.
And so there was a whole 'nother scene or
two where we met The Mandarin in China and
he was manipulating Obadiah Stane and there
was another big action sequence.
And that felt too comic booky to me because,
for these movies to work, I was running marketing
from Marvel's perspective.
I didn't delegate that.
I was going to every meeting as the chairman
of Marvel Studios, I had the relationship
with Rob Moore to get the best out of Paramount.
Kevin was on set every day and so we would
talk about everything, of course.
And I'd go to set many times and Kevin would
come to marketing meetings.
But we needed to appeal from a marketing point
of view to non-comic book fans.
Otherwise, we would have died.
Only four or five thousand people read Iron
Man comics.
So I needed the movie to be appealing to my
mom, my girlfriend at the time, the whole
world.
And so it had to be a classic story about
a man changing his life who happened to change
into being the superhero and making other
big decisions.
And so my Spidey sense was the story was getting
too comic booky in act three.
And we needed to make it more Shakespearean
where the father figure of Obadiah was the
villain.
So I went in as studio chairman where I could
have dictated that and told Jon Favreau and
Kevin, "We're chopping off that part of the
movie."
But instead I went in, I remember first calling
Ike and Jon and telling them what I thought
about and my discomfort, and then going in
and calling a meeting and recommending it
and explaining why to Jon and to Kevin and
to the team rather than just ordering it.
And to their credit, they embraced it pretty
quickly.
Which we had to do because we were pretty
close to getting to production.
That, I think, made the story, we all believed,
better.
We kept The Mandarin for a later film and
we saved money on the budget too because we
didn't have to do that scene.
And we probably didn't piss off China at the
time.
So we had a lot of benefits from that decision.
Tim Ferriss: Win, win, win.
I don't know Robert Downey Jr.
I don't know Kevin.
But I have spent some time with Jon, he's
been on the podcast.
And I just want to strongly plus-one that
he is one of the most talented people.
And that's not to diminish the hard work that
goes into it.
I should say, skilled people on a multitude
of levels that I have met.
And really knows how to do what you were describing
in terms of embracing the comedy but not making
it overly slapstick, and getting a lot out
of performances on screen.
He's really, really exceptional.
And also just very, very, at least in all
of my experiences, just a very pleasant guy
to be around.
David Maisel: He is.
We had a blast on set.
And the other thing Jon did really well, to
your point there, is we didn't freeze the
script on Iron Man.
Which most people would say is crazy because
each day costs three or 500,000 depending
on the day of cost.
So if you miss your day and you don't finish
everything, you blow that money.
But we kept time for Robert to improvise.
And Jon managed that and Kevin, and they did
a great job.
And Jon is the director.
And so many of the lines that you probably
love that so many people love came out of
Robert improvising.
And that was a risk.
And I felt very secure in that, given Jon's
expertise, like you say.
Tim Ferriss: It worked out.
Let's look at the series of events.
And I'd love for you to walk us through the
milestones or the key moments between Iron
Man and the sale to Disney.
Before we get to that, I have to ask, because
you've mentioned it a few times, why so quiet
with PR?
Why haven't you done more PR?
David Maisel: It relates to what you're about
to ask me, the sale to Disney, which, I try
to live life intentionally.
And one of the things that I've tried to avoid
is to get too focused on my own, I guess,
ego, for lack of a better word.
And so one of the reasons I sold the company
to Disney, one big reason was shareholder
value and get the best price.
And the other was me, personally, I was okay
with it because I wanted to venture away and
do new challenges.
And we can get back to that.
But I realized that if I opened the door on
the PR side, it would just be a route that
didn't interest me at the time and I'd be
talking about the past all the time.
I, fortunately, did well with the sale of
Marvel to Disney.
And so obviously I could have afforded PR
people, and I just never did that.
And that was my reason.
I just thought it was unnecessary.
I didn't realize, Tim, at the time, it's a
different discussion, I always thought truth
always prevailed.
And we've learned, in a lot of parts of our
lives in the past eight years, that that truth
is fungible.
And so it was something whereby being quiet,
there was a lot of confusion about all the
stuff that we talked about.
I found my story, essentially, being somewhat
rewritten out of history, which is really
weird when it's eight years of your life and
something that was your vision and dream.
And to the point of articles being written
where they just didn't even mention what we
just talked about.
And one famously in the cover of Vanity Fair
a few years ago.
And the same author of that article is writing
a book that's coming out on the history of
Marvel Studios, coming out in November.
Joanna Robinson, who now has done her research
and knows the story that we've talked through
and realizes the mistake that they made.
So the past couple years, I've realized two
things.
One, I enjoy telling the story.
It's a big part of who I am.
My friends knew, people like Bryan Lourd and
Kevin Feige and my Hollywood friends knew,
and the people in Hollywood that mattered.
But even in many cases, if they don't see
it written and so on, it gets confusing.
So I've realized that if you care about something,
it's important to be part of the narrative.
Luckily for Marvel, it's so big and it's done
so well that there's plenty of shine to share.
As I mentioned Avi, I give him full credit
for the license deals of which I would not
have been able to open some of the doors I
did.
And Kevin, I'm his biggest fan.
I'm proud of my vision for Marvel Studios
and where it came from me.
Whether it's my future wife or it's people
listening to this podcast, that's part of
who I am.
I'm proud of going there and making it happen
and putting on all those different hats that
we talked about that were needed at the time.
And I'm proud of handing the baton to Kevin
and the sale to Disney.
And so there's enough great credit for everybody
to have and hopefully everybody sees that
once all the facts come out.
This is a big step in talking about PR.
And it's fun to tell the story to people.
There's so many different angles to it.
And the other part that's been a big influence
is when my mom was recently sick, a lot of
the doctors and nurses and other people around
her I'd have time with and I would tell them
the story, and I realized how it affected
their lives.
They'd go home and tell their kids they — with
the guy who founded Marvel Studios.
And not everyone gets to meet us and have
these discussions.
And I realized Marvel brings a lot of joy
in people's lives.
I just flew back from Miami yesterday and
I have a Marvel bag with me.
The security guy at the airport was all excited
and he helped me through security, which was
a good benefit.
So there's actually a selfish benefit of carrying
a Marvel bag.
Tim Ferriss: Well, pro-tip, get some Marvel
bags.
I'm really glad that you're willing to take
the time to have this conversation.
I'm having a lot of fun.
I'm learning a lot.
I'm taking notes not only about your entire
journey with Marvel, but I'm going to watch
All That Jazz.
And there's more —
David Maisel: Great.
Tim Ferriss: — of course in the notes.
But let's talk about Iron Man to sale.
And you can walk us through that in any way
that makes sense.
And I'll leave it to you to guide us.
David Maisel: As we were making the film,
I mentioned that things went smoothly from
spring of 2006 to May 2nd, 2008.
They didn't really go smoothly in terms of
people's perception of the movie.
They went smoothly in us making it, us feeling
good about it.
But nobody really believed — our stock went
down for four and a half years.
So I came in, my options were at 19 bucks
a share.
When Iron Man came out, I think the stock
was trading at $18 a share.
Not for lack of trying.
I was on CNBC touting Marvel.
Ike famously doesn't really care about press,
but even he agreed we should do press.
And so we had articles in Businessweek at
the time and Fortune and Financial Times and
all these other places.
And New York Times as well, a famous article
that I keep by my office door, which talks
about all the risks about Marvel.
This was like a 2006 or 2007 article.
And at the end of the article, I'm like, "We're
doing this really in a smart, creative way,
and people are going to love it."
It sounded like I was crazy on the street.
So even Paramount projected we were going
to do about 40 or 50 million for the weekend.
And my board came finally to L.A. They didn't
care about it really too much from that point
of view, but we had the premiere.
And I remember my board telling me that Kevin
and I would get, I think it was a half a million
dollar bonus each if the film broke even.
And so that was my own company was like, "Hey,
attaboy, way to go.
Breaks even, we'll make money on the toys."
I think we were immune to it.
I think Kevin and I, and I think Jon and Robert,
we were so immersed in making the movie and
we felt so good about it, that for some reason
that lack of confidence in the Wall Street
or otherwise didn't affect us too much, but
it was there.
It's important to realize that.
Because I was having lunch with Bob Iger probably
once a year since I joined and Kevin Mayer,
and I'd wear my Spider-Man tie and stuff like
that.
But it was only after Iron Man came out did
I really start thinking, "Where does this
company go?"
And we had Hulk coming out a month later,
and that film, a lot of people misunderstand.
They're wondering why we did it.
And like I said, we did it to get the rights
back for Hulk as a supporting character in
movies like The Avengers.
And we had to make that movie for that.
And we planned the budget of that movie to
break even, as long as it did the first film.
So we weren't expecting it to break out like
Iron Man did.
But the night Iron Man came out, I was at
a man named Ron Burkle's house, who had become
a mentor and still is.
And I got a phone call from Rob Moore at 6:00
p.m., "Hey, we're going to do 60 million."
An hour later, "70 million."
Every hour it went up 10 million.
And finally it did 100 million at 10:00 p.m.
at night on Friday night.
And I knew things had changed from Marvel,
they changed for Jon, Robert, Kevin and I.
Tim Ferriss: What a night.
Can I just pause to say or actually pause
to ask, what did that feel like?
What was your experience as you're getting
these updates hour by hour?
David Maisel: Yeah, by the way, it's still
unreal.
Telling the story to you, I still pinch myself
every day that I was able to go from reading
Iron Man comics to having this crazy dream,
to making Marvel into what it is today is
crazy.
And kids ask me, "How do you do that?"
And it doesn't happen.
And so when Iron Man came out and we knew
the number, the adrenaline was just huge.
We had just had the premiere, people seemed
buzzed about it, but until we got that box
office number — you get really busy.
You have to give quotes right away.
And we had a Wall Street analyst meeting coming
up that next Tuesday.
And so you get busy doing things, but I probably
didn't really celebrate it till later in the
summer.
We did have a dinner that people might be
interested in.
So I organized a dinner at Mr. Chow's, a famous
restaurant in L.A., in Beverly Hills, with
Jon Favreau, Robert Downey, Kevin, and myself
to celebrate.
And it was a couple of weeks after Iron Man
opened.
And Kevin and I had suggested to Ike that
we buy cars for Robert and Jon as presents
for them.
And we had worked with their wives to figure
out what cars they want.
And so Favreau had picked this Mercedes and
Robert a Bentley.
And so at Mr. Chow's, we swapped Favreau's
car.
So he drove in with whatever old car he had,
and we knew he was going to get his Mercedes.
And we brought Robert in on the joke.
So I'll come back to that in a second.
But at dinner we celebrated and I said, "Guys,
I will greenlight Iron Man 2 if everyone around
this table..." and I looked at Jon and Robert
and Kevin, "...commit to making it so we can
release it May 2nd, 2010," or whatever the
equivalent weekend was, which was really quick
for a movie with no script.
And I think everyone was sort of surprised.
Things don't just happen that way in Hollywood.
So a lot of what we did in this movie was
like film school.
I mean, Natalie Portman I was introduced to
by Leo DiCaprio.
We wanted Natalie to be in Thor.
She had no desire, Kevin Huvane was her agent,
to really be in it.
And then he knew I wanted her in the movie
and he was bowling with her one night and
texted me to get dressed and come out to a
midnight bowling in Hollywood.
And he introduced me to her and said, "You
two should work together."
So it was really like kids in film school.
So it all worked out for everybody.
So we did celebrate.
And then at the end of that night, we gave
Jon his new car.
But the funniest part was Robert was in on
the joke, but there was no car for him.
And we did that on purpose so that he'd get
like, "Where the hell's my car?"
in his mind.
And so we waited a week, so he'd be wondering.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, brutal, brutal.
David Maisel: Yeah.
His wife told us when he was taking a nap
one afternoon and we brought it into his driveway,
so when he woke up, he saw it in his driveway,
which was fun.
Tim Ferriss: That's incredible.
That's so fun.
David Maisel: So we had fun with it a bit.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So you mentioned these regular
meals, I think it was with Bob Iger.
And then you mentioned Ron Burkle, who has
become and still is a mentor.
I want to pick up on those two.
What was the context of meeting with Bob on
a regular basis?
Was it just to keep in touch, to swap stories,
to give news from the front lines in your
respective worlds?
What was the context?
David Maisel: In a stepping back for your
audience.
It wasn't just having meals.
I called Bob a couple of times with business
proposals.
One of the times, I said, "Let's do animated
movies.
50-50 Marvel, Disney."
And that didn't go anywhere.
And so we had a habit of talking about business
opportunities, but our stock was so low in
February of 2009 that I didn't raise a sale
at all.
And then importantly, and this is all public,
because when you do things as a public company,
the SEC makes you go back for five years,
every email, every meeting, every communication
I had with Bob, with Kevin Mayer or anybody
else at Disney is public record.
But I called Bob at the end of May.
Our stock was back up to 35.
I felt that Disney stock was also undervalued.
It was at $25 a share with the economic collapse.
And Disney, as a company, is very sensitive
to the economy.
People go to theme parks more often, they
do stuff like that.
And so I felt like I was a big Disney shareholder,
or I follow the stock closely at least, that
Disney was at least a double when the economy
recovered.
Whereas we were at two movies a year at best,
and could be plateaued for a while.
And Dreamworks Animation was a company that
also had two movies a year, and they were
plateaued.
So all of that in my mind, when I saw our
stock hit 35 or 36 or 37, I called Bob, we
organized a secret meeting in his office for
early June.
I brought my Marvel encyclopedia of characters
with me.
And that's the meeting where — this is news
for your listeners.
There was two deals that we had on the table
that would've encumbered us.
Encumbering means we would've tied up our
rights, and been way less attractive for a
potential purchaser.
We were about to extend our distribution deal
on the movies beyond what Paramount had to
another studio.
I won't name them on this thing yet.
But we were very close to doing another 10
or 20 movies to them.
And we were about to do a kids' TV network
with Discovery and Hasbro, which ended up
being called The Hub.
So I remember David Zaslav at the time, and
Brian Goldner, the CEO of Hasbro, recently
passed away.
The three of us were working on this, and
I was working on this other deal.
So I knew that there was a window to sell
the company, that six months later we'd be
way less attractive to Disney or anyone else
because we'd be committed to somebody else
in TV and then somebody else in film.
And I was gun shy.
I knew how easily a deal can fall apart from
my previous time suggesting this at Disney.
So all of that was in my mind in June when
I went to see Bob.
And I remember telling Bob about our TV deal
with Discovery and Hasbro.
And him saying, "Hold on, let's do a TV deal
with Disney.
And we'll do a primarily male but kids, teenager
entertainment network."
And I joked with him, I said, "No, not going
to get a little bit pregnant.
We either do something big or we don't."
And he took that, to his credit, and said,
"Then let's think something big."
And I remember vividly him saying — I said,
"I think we would need $50 a share.
We need a five in front of it."
So we went pretty far in this meeting.
And he knew I knew Kevin Mayer, and he knew
I knew Tom Staggs, who was CFO at the time,
I think.
And he basically said, "Will my board and
Kevin and Tom think that's a fair price?"
And I said, "Absolutely."
I said, "I've got this thing planned out for
the next 10 years."
And so since I had done work for Bob, he,
I think, had some trust in that.
And we talked about the vision of connecting
all the characters and what the future movies
were going to be.
Iron Man 2 was our next movie.
We had delayed Thor, so I knew that would
be good to have Iron Man 2 as the next movie
because that's predictable.
And I explained how we're leading up to The
Avengers, and how everything after Iron Man
would be a sequel to Iron Man.
Everything after Avengers is a sequel to Avengers,
which I think has proved to be the case.
And that was first week of June, 2009.
We announced the deal the end of August, two
months later, and we kept it secret.
And they ended up paying, I think it was 51
a share, and we got 40 percent of it in Disney
stock.
We wanted 50 percent.
And so that was a great trade for our shareholders,
and turned out to be one.
And Disney got up to 180 or 200 at some point.
Now they're close to 100 even with their correction.
And so I remember meeting with Kevin Mayer
right after that.
We didn't even have a banker.
And I went through my projections with Kevin
and as friends, we yelled at each other, swore
at each other, all that kind of stuff.
I was basically saying, "For Captain America
and Thor, you need to give us credit for 80
percent of Iron Man in your model."
And he's like, "No, it should be 60 percent.
No one cares about those characters," whatever.
And then I said, "Iron Man 2 should be like
110 percent of Iron Man, and Avengers should
be like 150 percent of Iron Man."
He's like, "No, Avengers is a new movie.
That should be like Captain America or Thor."
And I was like, "No."
Robert Downey we had signed up for The Avengers,
so it's basically a quasi-Iron Man sequel.
It's an interesting story because I'm negotiating
with someone I worked with that I've known
for decades with a company where I worked
at intimately.
And to your question though, after that first
meeting, I went to that meeting, Ike didn't
even know I was having a meeting.
And if he did know, he would not be surprised
because it would be about a business deal,
that kind of stuff.
I called Ike from in front of Team Disney
after leaving Bob.
And I was as pumped about this meeting as
I was about Iron Man's box office because
I could see the excitement in Bob's eyes.
It turns out that they had internally been
reviewing options, and Marvel was on their
list, though they hadn't proactively contacted
anybody, including myself.
And I called Ike and I told him that I think
I have a buyer for the company.
And I thought there'd be one of three responses,
Tim.
Even though Iron Man had came out, even though
it was my idea to do the MCU or this new Marvel
Studios self-financed, self-producing and
connecting the characters, I want to come
back to it in a second, but even with all
that, I knew Ike might say, "You're fired,"
right on the spot.
Or more likely, "Get your ass back to the
office and work on Iron Man 2," and other
initiatives that we were doing as a company.
But he said, "Fly to New York, come see me."
And I made a reservation to come right away,
like the next morning or whatever.
And I wrote on the airplane what my scenario
planning would be, and so he was open-minded
to it once I got there and made the case.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Okay.
So he didn't lop your head off, didn't march
you off with the guards.
David Maisel: No.
Tim Ferriss: Well, that seems to speak volumes
to his character and presence of mind to be
able to mentally, having committed for so
long to not selling, nor even entertaining
the possibility of a sale, to endure the cognitive
dissonance of considering it as an option.
I mean, that's no small feat.
David Maisel: Yeah, and I think that's a trait
I saw in Ike all the way through.
He's notorious for being very fiscally conservative,
and some people mistake that for not being
supportive of major decisions.
And he did hire me and gave me a chance with
Marvel Studios.
And here he gave me a chance.
He still wasn't convinced, but he at least
wanted to hear my case.
And it took a while to convince him.
And then the major thing was Bob and Ike had
to get together.
And so in the meeting with Bob, I remember
Bob said, "What do we need to do?"
He even asked me, "What do you want out of
this, David?"
And I said, "No, no, you have to make Ike
happy.
That's the person that has to be convinced."
And I had basically understood from Bob that
if Ike didn't want to do something that this
wouldn't go anywhere.
And so I arranged a meeting in New York, where
Bob came to the offices at nine o'clock at
night.
And he and Ike, I let them go to dinner.
I kept back and I didn't ask to go.
And they had a wonderful dinner.
And I think this is public, Bob had Steve
Jobs call Ike and talked to him how well Bob
preserved Pixar's culture after the sale.
And so all of that really helped get this
across the finish line and — yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Incredible.
What a story.
Wow, what a wild adventure.
How does Ron Burkle fit in as your mentor
in all of this?
And maybe just in a snapshot, explain just
enough background so that people can conjure
an image of someone.
David Maisel: Ron is most famous for owning
Ralphs grocery stores.
He started as a bagger and became the owner,
and became a billionaire through that and
other investments.
And he's notorious as a very savvy investor
and a very hard businessman in terms of the
terms that he requests for investments.
I don't know exactly where we met, but I think
we met at one point when he was interested
in buying Endeavor when I was working with
Ari in the early days.
And that deal didn't go anywhere, but Ron
and I became friends.
And then he watched my career at Marvel and
the relationship grew deeper.
We had Leo as a mutual friend, and so we had
social acquaintances in common as well.
But no, the intersection with the Marvel story
is I was at his house for a party that night
when the box office came out.
The night before Iron Man came out, Kevin
and Robert and Jon and I went to theaters
together to see the Thursday night shows,
and that was a blast because it was the first
time we saw a live audience watching the films.
We didn't test market these movies at all.
And yeah, that was exciting.
We wanted Robert to sell tickets, but they
wouldn't let us have him do that.
Tim Ferriss: Why didn't you test market it?
I'm curious.
So no test audiences?
David Maisel: It's very atypical.
We could have really blown this, Tim.
I mean, yeah, we went a lot with our instincts
and the collective group.
And I'm trying to remember if we ever had
one.
I don't recall it happening.
No.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
So you mentioned the dinner, the turning point
dinner with Bob and Ike, and then a lesser-known
fellow named Steve Jobs calling Ike to talk
about Pixar.
And then we know how that story, in a sense,
ends, at least from the public perspective,
which is in the successful acquisition.
Are there any other points along that path
that you would like to mention or fill in?
David Maisel: Yeah.
I think from a deal perspective, besides negotiating
the percentage in Disney stock, we were pretty
close to what Bob and I spoke to in that first
meeting.
And then it became about keeping Marvel as
a separate company within Disney, so the culture
didn't get messed up.
And I specifically wanted to step aside and
I introduced, I told Bob about Kevin, how
I thought he could run the Marvel entity within
Disney in a uniquely great way.
And then, Bob got to meet Kevin and see for
himself.
And so that was a big part because personally
I wanted to go on to different ventures and
different parts of my life.
And selling to Disney allowed me to do that
in a very clean way, both financially with
other shareholders to be able to afford that.
And then two, easier to leave a company when
it's a division of a bigger company than by
itself.
And so, that for me was, personally, in addition
to the deal time, it was sort of exciting
to think about my next venture and scary,
because I didn't quite know who I was outside
of my role at Marvel and what that person
would be.
But besides that, the deal went through pretty
well.
And the price of it, we got $4 billion, which
was about 3.8 billion more than the price
when I joined.
And we ran a lot of scenarios when I presented
to the board in 2004.
But the main scenario valued the new studio
as potentially in the three to four billion
dollar range.
And it came out close enough to that.
And our comic division and other things had
not really grown too much.
Our toy division, we went from making toys
to licensing, which sounds like a minor thing,
but it was big at the time.
But pretty much it was — a lot of people
now, I guess, are hearing Marvel Studios was
a startup within the parent company of Marvel.
But it was one that had to raise its own money.
It got the IP from the parent company.
But other than that, we had to manage it,
raise our own money, do our own deals.
And I was speaking to a tech entrepreneur
this past weekend in Florida from one of the
biggest tech companies in the world.
And he was very intrigued about how Marvel
Studios was a startup just like his company
was at the time.
And so, hopefully, that's interesting to a
lot of people that are hearing this.
Tim Ferriss: So David, I think this may be
a logical place to begin to wind to a close
with this first chapter of our ongoing conversation.
David Maisel: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: And I want to do a bit of teasing.
So next time, there's lots I would want to
talk about.
But broadly speaking, I'd want to talk about
some of your adventures outside of Marvel
and Disney.
So Angry Birds and other things, including
Ekos Genesis, which we will talk about at
some length.
And also how people might think about building
a universe, constructing a universe of characters.
What are the necessary steps, common mistakes,
et cetera, that you might be able to share
as lessons learned or things observed.
And I would say, I'll ask you two of my favorite
rapid fire questions.
The answers don't need to be rapid fire, but
the questions are intended to be short because
I can be very long-winded with my 17-part
questions.
This lead up is an example of that.
So the first question is, what books, if any,
have you gifted the most to other people or
recommended the most, that come to mind?
Or gifted a lot or recommended a lot to other
people?
Are there any books that come to mind?
David Maisel: The book I recommend to people
the most is Stranger In A Strange Land by
Robert Heinlein.
But I'm not sure that's —
Tim Ferriss: Such a good book.
David Maisel: Yeah, I'm not sure that's really
—
Tim Ferriss: That counts.
That counts.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Just because I think it's —
Tim Ferriss: That's a classic.
David Maisel: — awesome.
Yeah, and it's —
Tim Ferriss: It's an incredible book.
David Maisel: It's probably the live action
movie I would most like to make as an individual
movie.
You know what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: Hm.
David Maisel: Which could be interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That could be interesting.
All right.
Tim Ferriss: Let me ask you maybe a close
cousin of a question, which is not one of
my rapid fire.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But are there any properties,
characters, stories that you are not thinking
of pursuing yourself?
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That you just hope someone excellent
out there makes into a film or some type of
immersive world outside of its original format?
David Maisel: I love how you said film or
some other type of immersive world.
I think that's very savvy, by the way.
And we can get into that in the next discussion,
because I don't believe launching the next
universe is going to happen like Marvel did
through theatrical film.
I think it's going to start with something
else, and most likely will, because of the
way the world has changed.
And so I think the question in the topic,
as a tease for this next thing, when I left
Marvel, I had to figure out who I was from
a person point of view.
Would people still want to talk to me if I
wasn't running Marvel Studios, right?
Would I still be able to go to restaurants
and things like that?
Who my real friends were?
And then, from a business point of view, what
would catch my eye?
And what I'd say is, because of Marvel within
Disney and the power of the two together,
and because of how well Kevin has run Marvel
since, Marvel's gotten so big that the bar
to launch a new universe has gotten so high
and so much tougher because now you're competing
against Marvel, right?
So when I launched in 2008, Iron Man, we had
DC as a competitor, we had the Marvel-licensed
movies, Fox with X-Men, Sony with Spider-Man.
They were not just competitors, they could
use the Marvel brand.
So they were weird competitors.
We were scared about all these people.
But in retrospect, we had a relatively open
playing field because we didn't have ourselves
to compete with, the version of Marvel today,
which just dominates so much.
And we didn't have streaming, we didn't have
as much social media, all these other distractions
on people's time.
And it was tough, but it's like an old saying,
"How good we had it, we didn't realize."
Still very tough, but now it's even harder.
So something that goes through the filter
you're talking about has to be pretty special
to hop into what we call a universe category,
or major, a potentially new mythology.
And I'd love to talk about that more because
it is something that a lot of people do ask
about and a lot of people are focused on.
Obviously, DC just hired a new person to run
DC after 15 years or 20 years of us being
able to do what we did at Marvel.
David Zaslav, when he bought Warner Brothers
from AT&T, said, "I want to copy Marvel, I
want to do what Marvel did."
But we did that 15, 20 years ago.
So it shows you even DC hasn't gotten their
act together in the same way.
And that's a very well-capitalized company
with a large number of properties.
So it's very hard for a new universe to get
created.
I don't think it's impossible, but it's got
to be differentiated from Marvel so that there's
a reason that it exists.
I think it has to be introduced in new ways
that you sort of tease with new technologies
and new ways of storytelling, probably has
to be way more primal and visual so it gets
people's quick attention.
They can see what's there.
I think it has to have great meaning, Tim.
Marvel had a good meaning in that it's great
to be a hero.
And I think people relate to something that
they feel is adding to their lives in somehow,
whether they sense it or it's just subconscious.
That's what all mythologies from Greek and
Roman onward have done, or before even Greek
and Roman mythology.
And it has to be something, I think — listen,
James Cameron with Avatar has probably done
the best since Marvel came out with big cultural
moments.
Now he does things every 10 years though,
right?
But that was an original idea.
I think the next thing probably is a legacy
property, but it is still, like Marvel, it
had history, but people could discover it
together.
So it was the perfect combination.
And I think people love to discover something
with their friends, and the idea of the new
band or something in new technology, there's
just something great.
I hear you and Kevin talking on podcasts,
like two friends discovering things together,
whether it be pipe smoking or whether it be
something else.
And it's like, yeah.
But there's something fun.
Pipe smoking's a good example.
That's a legacy activity that we understand
our grandparents did and people before them.
But it still felt new when you talked about
it with Kevin.
You know?
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
For sure.
David Maisel: And Marvel was legacy.
But for most people, they never read the comics.
It was new for them to talk with their friends.
"Did you see Iron Man?
Did you see all that?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Maisel: And so —
Tim Ferriss: It's like the youngsters these
days running around with Nirvana shirts on.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, it's really been this
resurgence of grunge popularity.
I'm like, "Wow, didn't see that coming."
David Maisel: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
David Maisel: Yeah.
And if there's no legacy, then it's just purely
new.
You don't get into the geekiness like with
pipes.
How was it done a hundred years ago?
And look at this pipe, it's a collectible
or whatever, you know?
You don't have all that.
And if it's completely legacy, but it's so
big, then there's no thrill of discovery,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Maisel: So it's the balance on the scale
of those things.
Tim Ferriss: You know who I think did a really
nice job?
This is within serial television, but Stranger
Things, because they were tapping into all
of these hot-button passions from decades
ago.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But at layering on top of that,
novel storylines.
David Maisel: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: I thought it was executed extremely
well.
David Maisel: Agreed.
Tim Ferriss: I haven't watched beyond season
one, but I thought, "Wow, that's a really
smart combination."
David Maisel: So I think we just answered
the question about new universes by comparing
it to pipe smoking, so.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Any other questions?
So David, is there — I'm going to skip my
other question.
I'll save it for next time, which is the billboard
question.
I'll advise you in advance so that you have
some heads-up.
But is there anything else you would like
to add before we come to a close?
Anything else —
David Maisel: I think —
Tim Ferriss: — you'd like to make a request
of the audience, comment, recommendation,
philosophical note or two?
Anything at all.
David Maisel: No, I appreciate that.
And I will think about that also for part
two.
But I think we went into a lot of details
about what happened in 2003 through the sale
to Disney in 2010, whether it be financing
or distribution or the sale.
And I think, stepping back for a second, there
was also a simple pursuit of something you
really believed in and that you're passionate
about.
And when I think to myself, what happens if
I didn't go to Marvel or if Ike didn't take
that meeting or didn't hire me, or if I took
the — Michael Jackson didn't get arrested?
Tim Ferriss: Thank God for the timing on that
one.
David Maisel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Not being halfway through that.
David Maisel: The butterfly effect of no new
Marvel Studios for Disney to have, for no
Avengers movie.
Because one of the things we didn't talk about
is if the movies are all licensed at different
studios, they never get mixed together.
So to create Avengers, to mix the characters,
we had to own and keep the rights ourselves.
And so, just legally, these characters would
never be mixed together.
And there wouldn't be this interrelated universe,
and the ripple effect and everything else
is so big.
And I do think, as people think about their
lives and they think about their decisions,
we all have that butterfly effect somehow,
almost every day, on decisions we make.
And that might not be as evident as no Avengers
movie or something as big culturally, but
it's exciting to realize that your life has
that potential.
In your own personal life, you and your focus
on health had a butterfly effect on me getting
healthy recently these past six months, and
a mutual friend hearing that story and introducing
us, right?
So, even this podcast comes from that chance
event happening.
And I think that's one of the big lessons
from that.
That even if you are just with your family
or your friends, the effect of your actions
and everything else does create all these
cool things in life.
And it creates wonder and awe about what life
can be, and sometimes real passion and dreams
can become reality.
And in this crazy world that we live in, it's
probably the biggest sentiment I can say to
people.
Tim Ferriss: What a great place to wrap up
also.
Hear, hear.
So thank you, David.
Makes me want to get out there, get after
it, or just sit down and do some doodling
because you just never know where it's going
to go.
David Maisel: That's true.
Tim Ferriss: And these huge things often start
off just as a glimmer in some handful of neurons.
And then, look at where that's led.
What a wild story.
And people can find you, I'll link to all
these in the show notes, but on social and
other places, they can find you on Twitter
@maiseldavid.
That's spelled M-A-I-S-E-L, David, D-A-V-I-D.
They can find Ekos Genesis, @EkosGenesis on
Twitter, E-K-O-S Genesis, for people who want
a preview of part of what we'll be discussing
next time.
And the website for that is ekos.io.
And so nice to spend time with you, David.
I really appreciate you blocking out the time
to have this conversation.
David Maisel: I feel the same.
It's been a pleasure talking through this
stuff and I look forward to part two.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
More to come, more to come.
And for everybody listening, as always, we
will have show notes, links to everything
we discussed at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a bit kinder
than is necessary, not only to other people,
but also to yourself.
And as always, thank you for tuning in.